Jetzt bin ich am Start. Möb, Dankeschön für den Sub. 17 Jahre schon am Start.
Übrigens wir haben neue Emotes, falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt.
Was ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, weil die haben wir erst seit 10 Minuten oder so.
Wir haben jetzt, ich zeig's euch mal kurz.
Wir haben jetzt, wir haben jetzt, wupp, war mal groß, dass man so ordentlich erkennt.
Wir haben, ich muss mal, ich muss mal raussuchen.
Ah, eins, zwei, drei, drei, vier.
Ich glaub das sind die neuen.
Hab ich nichts vergessen.
Sechs Stück, ich hab nur fünf gepostet, was hab ich vergessen?
Hat hab ich vergessen.
Den haben wir auch noch.
Ich hab aber immer noch, ich hab immer noch fünf Standard, also fünf Free Emote Slots
frei, drei Tier 1, ein Tier, nee, ein Animated, fünf Tier 2, fünf Tier 3 und Bits und so
Gedöns hab ich immer noch, also sprich ich kann noch, ja lassen wir mal die Tier Subscriptions
weg, das ist eh Blödsinn.
Eins, vier, neun, neun Emotes kann ich noch hochladen, eins davon animiert.
Also das erste Emote, die ersten fünf Emotes oder so, die wir hatten, waren ja unter anderem
sowas hier, ich finde das, ich finde das Source, das ist so alt, ich finde den Source, das
Source schon gar nicht mehr vor den Bildern.
Also ich mein ich hab das irgendwo auf dem Rechner, auf dem alten garantiert und auch
im Backup, aber ich hab keine Ahnung wo.
So, ah gucken ob Windows nicht wieder in der Lautstärke Regelung rumgespielt hat, wahrscheinlich.
Guck hier, guck hier, Leute, alter Windows, muss auf 73, sonst ist das viel zu leise man,
das Logging, Alter, ah man, du du du, habt ihr mal ne Idee, warum ist die Windows Suche
eigentlich so unbrauchbar scheiße, woran könnt's liegen, findest mit dem Ding nix,
ich benutze gleich find und grab, über die, über das Terminate anstatt die Windows Suche,
wenn das so weitergeht.
Neuer PC, ja der neue PC, der ist halt ungefähr, den, irgendwie so, ich glaub an Weihnachten
hatte ich ihn schon.
Also jetzt glaub ich, 3 Wochen oder so, 2-3 Wochen, warum die Windows Suche so scheiße
ist, Microsoft nicht kann, wie macht man das Startmenü nach unten links, da, da, du musst,
du musst in Taskbar Behaviors gehen oder in Taskbar Verhaltensweise oder sowas, keine
Ahnung, wie das auf Deutsch heißt, Woop Arrive, weiß ich nicht, der Chainlord hat's anscheinend
gelöscht, ich hab das nicht gelöscht, Woop Leaf gibt's, doch Woop Arrive ist immer noch
da, ist doch noch da, das ist G-Bait, du hast kein Leerzeichen dazwischen gemacht, das ist,
das ist G-Bait, du hast da irgendwelche Unicode Zeichen drin oder so, machs mal mit dem Autocomplete
vom, von deiner, von deiner Extension, ja also hier kannst du es irgendwo einstellen, man
kann es ganz davon abgesehen, dass ich nicht verstehe, warum man eine eigentlich ganz gut
funktionierende Taskleiste aus Windows XP und irgendwie auch aus Windows 7 komplett
umbauen musste und Windows 8 hat ja sowas nicht, ja, komplett umbauen musste zu diesem
Ding aus Windows 10 und es jetzt nochmal neu entwickeln musste zu noch weniger Funktionen
für Windows 11, das erschließt sich mir nicht, aber was auch, was auch extrem nervig, aber
Leute übrigens, guckt mal hier, ihr werdet sich glauben, guckt mal was ich installiert
hab, seht ihr das, habt ihr, habt ihr, habt ihr es gesehen, ich hab tatsächlich Office
installiert, was da passiert ist, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, aber ich hab mir ein Office
dran 65 Abo gekauft, es sind Sachen, die hätte ich selbst nicht
vermutlich gehalten, ne Outlook werde ich nicht verwenden, kann man vielleicht, ich
würde gerne selektiv da ein paar Sachen deinstallieren, zum Beispiel Access Alter, wer braucht denn
sowas, na egal, Outlook verwende ich nicht, verwende weiter Thunderbird, Outlook ist glaube
ich sinnvoll, wenn man da irgendwie Aufgabenplanung oder so, wobei kann man, kann man Outlook mittlerweile
ordentlich mit einem Caldav Server connecten, was ist der Grund dafür, weil man leider ab
und zu doch ein bisschen mit Office Zeug zu tun hat, 1TB OneDrive ist natürlich auch
ganz nice und es ist gar nicht so teuer, was kostet es denn glaube ich, 9,50€ im Jahr
oder sowas, also das kann man, das geht tatsächlich, ne 9, wie viel kostet das, hier 69 Dollar,
das geht eigentlich, be quiet, just blew my mind, alles klar, Ratchibuzz, rein für
E-Mail, ja, also Outlook ist sicherlich ganz nice, wenn man da noch Kalender und so drüber
macht, also warum ich, also ich hab meinen Caldav Kalender in Thunderbird und die E-Mails
in Thunderbird und halt auch die ganzen, die ganzen historischen E-Mail Postfläche, die
ich nur noch lokal liegen hab und sowas, die ich gar nicht mehr benutze, bisschen leiser
war, zumal Thunderbird halt auch überall läuft, wenn man, wenn man Outlook irgendwie
mit einem Caldav Kalender verbinden könnte, wäre das vielleicht doch ne Option, ja, ne
Exchange gibt es halt bei mir auch nicht, kann Outlook, kann das, ah ne da brauchst
du irgendeinen extra Synchronizer, das ist komplett schonmal unsinnig, wozu, was soll
ich damit, hast du schon über die neuen AMD Karten gesprochen, die haben ja einen massiven
Fehler im Kühler, ich hab mir das Video vom Aua angeguckt, der hat, wobei haben wir uns
das nicht sogar zusammen angeguckt, ich glaub das haben wir uns sogar zusammen angeguckt,
der hat ja zwei gemacht, das erste, wo er getestet hat, dass wenn die Karten in normaler
Einbaulage sind, sie Kühlprobleme haben, also horizontal, so wie sie halt im Gehäuse hängen
und das zweite Video war, wo er diesen, das hab ich glaub ich ohne euch geguckt, wo er
den Kühlkörper aufgeschnitten oder aufgemacht hat und wo sie dann von ausgehen, dass zu
wenig Kühlflüssigkeit drin ist, tja da hat AMD ziemlich reingekackt, ich frag mich halt
wie die das nicht feststellen können, da bin ich froh, dass ich kein Manager bei AMD
gerade bin, Leute und wie war für euch die erste Woche auf der Arbeit, ich geh mal davon
aus, dass auch viele von euch wieder ran mussten die Woche, oder musste die noch nicht, also
ich bin am dritten wieder hingegangen, wie ist denn bei dir auf der Arbeit die Stimmung
nachdem die Kündigung raus ist, ja die fanden ja schon alle ein bisschen doof, hatte ich
den Eindruck, aber ansonsten ja was sollen sie machen, wie sagen wir hier, Lab geht weiter,
also ich habe gehört, dass noch ein paar andere weg sind, von denen ich das noch nicht wusste,
ein paar die richtig angepisst sind, dass die Firma sich da überhaupt null bewegt, gut
das ist bei mir jetzt der Zug abgefahren, eine Sache habe ich jetzt festgestellt, aber
ich glaube die wird wahrscheinlich jeder nachvollziehen können, ich habe sehr wenig
Motivation gerade irgendwas anzufangen, also ich habe die gesamte Woche über, hatte ich
ein paar Meetings, ja ich habe auch eins zwei Sachen cherrypicked im Git und mir angeguckt,
aber insgesamt habe ich die erste Woche echt nicht viel gemacht und ich habe auch wenig
Bock gerade noch irgendwie großartig was zu machen, weil ich meine in drei Wochen, in
drei Monaten bin ich eh weg und achja eine lustige Geschichte, das ist ja auch wieder
typische geile Planung, wo ich gerade arbeite, also sie haben sich das eigentlich so gedacht,
also mein Chef wusste ja schon eine ganze Weile, dass ich abhau, das war wirklich kein
Secret, dem habe ich sie schon vor einer Weile erzählt, noch bevor ich unterschrieben
habe, so und eigentlich hatten sie geplant, das muss ich ein bisschen auswählen, also
wir waren vor einem Jahr noch ungefähr, ja vor einem Jahr noch, waren wir alle zusammen
in einem größeren Team, da hatten wir irgendwie 15 Leute oder so und irgendwann kam es auf
die glorreiche Idee, die ich bis heute nicht verstehen kann, das ist auch so ein Ding, wo
ich mir gedacht habe, okay wie wäre es mal mit den Leuten zu reden, was all was sie
eigentlich machen, weil ich bis heute nicht verstehen kann, weil im Prinzip hat sich nichts
geändert, aber organisatorisch hat man dann gesagt, ah das Team ist zu groß, da werden
jetzt drei Teams draus und danach haben sie versucht, nachdem sie die Leute da irgendwie
eingeteilt haben, irgendwie die Aufgaben noch hin und her zu schieben, das hat bis heute
noch nicht funktioniert, na gut zumindest einer der Leute dort wurde dann in ein anderes
Team quasi verschoben als ich, wir waren vorher in einem und das war im August letztes Jahr
und Ende diesen Jahres haben sie gesagt, ach wir brauchen dich ja gar nicht mehr, dann
ist ihnen aber wieder eingefallen, ach nee es wäre doch nicht schlecht, weil dann könnte
der ja wieder zurück in das andere Team, weil wenn der Max geht, dann könnte der ja Sachen
vom Max mitmachen, so und dann haben sie es nicht gebacken bekommen und haben tatsächlich
seinen Vertrag zum Ende des Jahres nicht verlängert und jetzt war er weg, das ist wirklich wieder
ein Planungsfail extrem und jetzt haben sie versucht ihn in der ersten Januarwoche wieder
zu kontaktieren, ob er nicht wieder zurückkommen will, also keine Ahnung, die Planung der Firma
check ich nicht so ganz, also wahrscheinlich haben sie jetzt irgendjemand, der das übernehmt
und weitgehend was ich mache, wobei ich da so meine Zweifel habe, ob das mit der Übergabe
so gut funktionieren wird, weil ganz im Ernst ich erzähle alles was ich weiß, das ist kein
Ding, aber ich werde jetzt mich selbst nicht wahnsinnig reinhängen, also wenn jetzt jetzt
jemand sagt, hey guck mal hier erzähl dir mal was mache ich das, aber ich renne den
Leuten nicht hinterher so nach dem Motto, ah ich würde dir gerne was erzählen, mal gucken
dann bin ich mal gespannt wie das wird, nice, ach du auch, ich war jetzt auch 10 Jahre da,
also das ist das 11 Jahr wo ich da war, das 11 Jahr, ich habe mich immer noch um die Jubiläumsfeier
gedrückt, Leute das wäre jetzt geil oder, ich gehe 3 Monate bevor ich abhaue gehe ich
auf die Jubiläumsfeier, das wäre jetzt, die ist jetzt demnächst, die machen, das ist einmal
im Jahr, das ist einmal im Jahr für alle 10 jährigen Leute die über 10 Jahre da sind
und wenn du abgesagt hast, dann laden die dich nächstes Jahr wieder ein so als möchtest
du denn jetzt unbedingt da irgendwann mal dran teilnehmen und ich habe halt abgesagt
letztes Jahr, dann müsste man jetzt eigentlich so 2 Monate bevor ich ab, 3 Monate bevor ich
abhaue, also Jungs, geiles Jubiläum, ja ich bin mal weg, ne ne mach ich nicht, ich bin
da froh das ich ja nicht hin musste bis jetzt, das war es muss, zwingen können sie mich
ja nicht, aber ich mag solche Feier nicht, das ist so gezwungen alles, also ich hab keinen
Bock, naja dann, nice, meine Woche war nicht produktiv, ich hatte keinen Bock neue Sachen
zu machen, sowas ja klar, oder aber kennst du auch die, oder kennt ihr auch die Leute,
die sagen, also du redest mit denen im Teams am Telefon oder vor Ort oder was auch immer
und die sagen, das schicke ich dir, das schicke ich dir, schicke ich dir alles, schicke ich
dir alles und 3 Monate später haben sie nix geschickt, denke ich mir auch immer, ist abzusehen
wann das Video kommt wo ihr dem Virus weiter auf den Grund geht, ja irgendwann nächste
Woche vermutlich, aber genau weiß ich es nicht, weil wir haben das noch nicht aufgenommen,
das heißt es ist auch unklar was da genau rauskommt, ja also wir gucken uns auf jeden
Fall die extrahierte neue Datei nochmal an plus diese andere Tempdatei und vielleicht
kriegen wir auch irgendwie was raus, was das eigentlich für Software ist und was sie damit
eigentlich vorhaben, vielleicht ist es ja was was Browser Sessions klaut, vielleicht ist es auch
nur irgend so ne Ransomware, wir haben dein Rechnerverschlüssel hier mal eine Runde Bitcoin
überweisen, keine Ahnung, das konnte man jetzt ja noch nicht sehen, hört sich an als würde
das Team schrumpfen, hört sich an als würde das Team, ja, mehr gehen als kommen, ja das ist
tatsächlich aktuell so, es gehen mehr Leute als kommen, das ist an ganz vielen Stellen dort wo ich
aktuell arbeite, so beispielsweise im Support, es ist kein Support, ich sage immer Support, aber
eigentlich glaube ich mögen die das gar nicht wenn ich Support sage, das ist ein wie nennt man
sowas, Operation Center oder sowas, weiß nicht wieder der krasse BWL, ITIL, sonst was Name ist,
also das ist ein Team, die sind 24 7 da, mehrere Schichten und die gucken auf Monitoring und
Wartungsarbeiten und solche Geschichten und ob was kaputt geht und dann ziehen sie die Leute, wenn
sie selbst nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, ziehen sie die Leute auch nachts hinzu, die ihnen da helfen
können, wie nennt man es, Operation Center oder sowas, so also da ist es bei uns auch so, da sind
jetzt, ist auch geil, da sind die letzten Jahre über, also die letzten Jahre sind, bezieht sich
auf irgendwie letzten vier Jahre, letzten vier Jahre über suchen die schon Leute, also ursprünglich
sollten sie glaube ich 14 Leute sein im Team, damit sie drei Schichten am Tag abdecken können, also
sie haben Frühschicht, tagsüber Schicht und Nachtschicht oder tagsüber Spätschicht und Nachtschicht,
also drei Schichten immer jeweils jeweils acht Stunden und da soll es eigentlich so sein, dass
solche Schichten immer mit mindestens zwei Leuten besetzt sind, weil tagsüber ist oftmals viel los
und nachts könnte es ja sein, dass du einen Herzinfarkt kriegst und keiner kriegt es mit,
also es sollten eigentlich immer zwei Leute da sein und das haben die schon eine ganze Weile,
können sie das nicht, achso ja und es muss ja auch Pause eingeplant werden, also die Leute
müssen Pause haben, die Leute müssen zwischendurch mal immer Ruhezeiten, Woche frei und sowas haben,
also sprich, das wurde mal ursprünglich ausgerechnet, dass diese diese Schichtplanung
auf nur aufrechterhalten werden kann, wenn es 13 oder 14 Leute sind und das heißt sie suchen
quasi seit Jahren Leute, so und wisst ihr wie viele Leute sie gefunden haben in den letzten vier
Jahren oder ich glaube sogar in den letzten fünf Jahren, das waren zwei Stück, die suchen permanent,
die suchen permanent, die haben zwei Leute gefunden, einer davon hat schon wieder letztes Ende letzten
Jahres gekündigt und der ganz neue, der da ist, der hat noch wenig, hat noch relativ wenig Ahnung
und die sind jetzt schon zu wenig, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt gehe, ich bin nicht in dem Team,
aber ich kriege das mit, weil ich sitze da in der Nähe, wenn ich jetzt gehe plus mein
Kollege, den ich mitnehme zum neuen Arbeitgeber, dann sind die glaube ich nur noch 9 oder so
und ihr merkt schon das Problem, dass sie keine Schichten mehr richtig besetzen können und teilweise
Leute alleine da sitzen und so, das ist ganz ganz grausam und sie kriegen es halt überhaupt nicht
auf die Reihe Leute, Leute für sich zu gewinnen, es ist auch schwierig, nämlich ganz im Ernst,
Leute stellt euch mal vor ihr seht eine Stellenanzeige, wo Schichtarbeit drinne steht,
was macht ihr dann? Ist das Pog oder Not Pog? Also bei mir ist es eindeutig eher Not Pog,
eher Paynes Champ, wenn ich Schichtarbeit sehe in der Stellenanzeige, dann mache ich
Woopleaf direkt, richtig Woopleaf Instant Quit, das Problem was die haben mit der Stellenanzeige ist
aber auch, die Stellenanzeige an sich ist auch noch schlecht, also die ist so wirklich 0815 geschrieben,
wir sind ein dynamisches motiviertes Team und sowas in der Richtung, wo ich mir denke alter wer
will denn so ein Geblubber lesen, schreibt halt wirklich mal was rein, was es für Vorteile gibt,
es gibt ja tatsächlich Vorteile, aber da steht nichts drinne, ich habe denen sogar schon mal
einen Vorschlag geschrieben, wie man das, also wie ich es ansprechend erfinden würde, natürlich
muss ich das ein bisschen in Business Sprache übersetzen, aber hat sich auch nichts getan,
es juckt da keinen und mich wundert es wirklich nicht, dass die keinen finden,
weil die Anzeige in sich ist schon wirklich schlecht, die Bezahlung ist ganz okay,
aber auch nur aus dem Grund, Stellanzeigen Review, ja da kann ich aber nicht sagen,
dass das die ist, die Bezahlung ist aber auch nur aus dem Grund ganz gut, weil das was man
als Zulage kriegt für Schichtarbeiten nicht oder weniger versteuert werden muss, ansonsten ist die
Bezahlung jetzt auch nicht so geil, also rein das Jahresgehalt auf dem Papier gesehen ist nicht so
der Wahnsinn, aber es bleibt halt relativ viel übrig davon auf dem Konto, weil man weniger
Steuern bezahlen muss. So und jetzt ist das Problem, das wie gesagt, einer der neun,
also sie waren eh schon nie genug, einer der neun ist schon wieder weg, der ganz neue hat noch
keine Ahnung und jetzt geht noch einer, das ist der, mit dem ich dann zum anderen, zum neuen
Arbeitgeber wechsle, plus die haben zwei Leute, die sind ziemlich alt, die gehen demnächst in
Rente, der eine hat sogar schon auf der Tafel, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, da hängt so ein
Whiteboard rum, da hat er sogar schon einen Countdown, wie viele Arbeitstage es noch sind
bis zur Rente, sind irgendwie noch 340 Tage bis zur Rente,
und die Arbeitstage stehen irgendwie daneben, also der ist quasi Ende des Jahres ist der quasi weg,
dann ist der in Rente, der andere braucht auch nicht mehr lange, noch ein weiterer hat, weil er
mit einer Amerikanerin verheiratet ist, hat irgendwie einen Green Card Antrag gestellt,
der gerade bearbeitet wird und wandert dann aus, wenn das durch ist, andere ist schon weg,
es wird eng, also sie kriegen es jetzt schon nicht hin, und es checkt irgendwie dort keiner,
die haben zwei Varianten, was sie machen können aus meiner Sicht, entweder mal eine ordentliche
Stellenanzeige schreiben, so dass man sich auch Bock hat, das zu machen, aber selbst dann wird
es natürlich schwierig, wenn das gar nicht stimmt, oder aber, die müssen die Leute zuschmeißen mit
Kohle, und oder oder dritte Variante ist, sie behalten alles so wie es jetzt ist und schrauben
ihre Ansprüche drastisch runter, die nehmen dann quasi jeden für relativ viel Kohle, auch
jeden der keine Ahnung hat, weil irgendwelche random Leute, die keinen Plan haben, kriegt es ja
natürlich, das könnten sie auch machen, das wollen sie natürlich nicht, also eigentlich bleibt
ihnen nur bessere Stellenanzeige schreiben und den Leuten mehr Geld, also offensiv mehr Geld bieten
und vor allem den Leuten, die dort sind, auch irgendwie Perspektive und und sowas bieten,
dass sie da bleiben, also das kriegen sie aber nicht hin und insofern ist das schwierig,
was witzig ist, ich habe jetzt gehört, dass dort intern irgendeine Ansprache gehalten wurde,
dass man ungern oder dass man nicht noch mehr Leute verlieren will und sich jetzt richtig
viel Mühe gibt und jetzt Team 2.0 und sowas startet und sowas, ist halt alles mehr oder weniger,
ich meine es sind ehrbare Absichten, ja ich glaube das dem Teamleiter dort auch,
dass er wirklich sich Mühe gibt und die Absichten hat das zu verbessern, aber letztendlich ist es
halt auch wahrscheinlich wieder heiße Luft, weil er kann da gar nicht so viel machen und naja egal,
es ist halt Fail, aber so sieht es aus. Kannst du da nicht irgendein Abkommen mit denen schließen,
dass du kein Geld kostest, wenn du eh kaum was machst? Hä, warum soll ich mit denen irgendein
Abkommen schließen, ich mache doch was. Ich könnte mit denen, also wo ich sofort dabei wäre ist,
wenn die mich irgendwie drei Monate freistellen und ich kriege weiter Geld, aber das werden sie
nicht machen, weil die wollen ja, dass ich mein Zeug übergebe und noch was mache, die haben zu
wenig Leute, die werden mir in der Sache nicht entgegenkommen, ich werde bis zum allerletzten
Tag dort arbeiten müssen. Ist ja auch nicht schlimm, ich gehe da jetzt, es ist ja nicht so, als gehe ich
da nicht, als gehe ich da total ungern hin. Die Home Office Geschichte ist das, was mich am meisten
halt genervt hat und nervt. Vielleicht werde ich einfach am nächsten Woche nicht mehr zweimal die
Woche hingehen, sondern nur noch einmal die Woche und mal gucken was passiert, weil was sollen sie
im Endeffekt machen, kann mich ja rausschmeißen. Nee, mal gucken, keine Ahnung. Ich werde das ganz
normal handhaben, bis 31.03. und dann ist gut. Kannst du ungefähr sagen, wie hoch das galt? Ja,
kann ich, ich kann dir aber nicht sagen, was übrig, also doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, warte mal,
warte mal, lass mal überlegen. Also, mir hat einer erzählt, dass es 85.000 im Jahr sind,
allerdings, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie er das gerechnet hat. Also hat er wirklich das genommen,
was auf seinem Vertrag steht? Ich vermute mal, okay, ich vermute mal, es ist folgendes, es sind 85.000
Euro im Jahr, da ist allerdings die ganze Zulage für Nachtarbeit, Schichtarbeit, Sonntagsarbeit,
Feiertagsarbeit und so schon mit drin. Das heißt, die bekommen am Ende wahrscheinlich unterm Strich
Jahres, Jahres, Brutto 85.000 Euro, nur, dass sie nicht so viele Steuern bezahlen müssen auf
ein Großteil dieses Geldes, weil es eben Nacht- und Schichtzulage ist, die anders besteuert wird.
Also, während wir wahrscheinlich rechnen können von 85.000 Euro, geht schon mal, keine Ahnung,
40% weg, also haben am Ende irgendwie noch, sag mal, 50.000 Euro übrig, haben die vielleicht
65.000 Euro übrig oder so, ich weiß es nicht genau, ich kann es ja nicht genau, so in dem Dreh,
denke ich, ist es aber mal und deswegen ist das gar nicht so übel, auch wenn es vielleicht auf dem
Papier jetzt nur okay und nicht super krass aussieht, aber unterm Strich kommt relativ viel an,
deswegen ist die Bezahlung gar nicht schlecht dadurch. Was sie übrigens in der Stellenanzeige
auch in keinem Wort erwähnen, ja, man könnte, man müsste ja nicht reinschreiben, hier super
krasse Megabezahlung, aber man könnte, wobei, wenn das einer reinschreiben würde, würde ich
mich zumindest mal bewerben oder fragen, was damit gemeint ist, aber man könnte ja zumindest
irgendwas Business-mäßige reinschreiben, dass man, ich meine, wenn man da reinschreibt,
überdurchschnittliches Gehalt oder sowas, das ist bla bla bla, da muss man schon ein bisschen
was Handfestes reinschreiben, dass die Leute sich da drauf bewerben, aber ich glaube, das
würde einige überzeugen, wenn sie es wüssten, ja, also irgendwie, es sind, es sind 85, ich glaube,
es sind 85.000 Euro brutto, was sie kriegen, aber davon müssen sie halt nicht so viel
Steuern bezahlen wie die meisten anderen, ja. Moin, Michael, 50 Billionen, guck mal,
hast du schon gesehen, wir haben jetzt, wir haben jetzt eigene Cute-Emotes.
So, ja, genau, so sieht es aus.
Viele Externe, das Problem, diesen externen Lifestyle haben sie bei uns jetzt auch schon,
dass sie an vielen Stellen Externe setzen, die dann halt relativ schnell weg sind. Ich meine,
Externe haben für das Unternehmen den Vorteil, die werden sich relativ schnell los. Das Blöde
dabei ist, dass jedes Mal, wenn davon einer geht, auch jede Menge Know-how abfließt. Man redet sich
irgendwie ein, das wäre nicht so, aber offensichtlicherweise und logischerweise
und jeder, der ist mitbekommen, ist es so, weil wenn jemand ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre oder länger
teilweise, wie die da sind, daran gearbeitet hat an irgendwas und selbst wenn der mal super
ordentlich ist, was ich jetzt von den meisten Externen nicht behaupten kann, dass sie super
viel Docs oder so schreiben, selbst dann kannst du es nicht einfach so abfedern, wenn einer abhaut,
ja. Also allein schon deswegen, ja, das ist bei uns auch so, zumal die Externe deutlich,
deutlich teurer sind. Natürlich wirst du sie einfacher wieder los, aber es bleibt dir
nichts anderes übrig. Aber letztendlich, hey, ich denke mir immer so, das denen ihr Geld soll
damit machen, was sie wollen, aber aktuell sieht man, dass das ziemlich gegen die Wand fährt.
Das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum ich mich vom Acker mache. Ich meine, ich mache mich
hauptsächlich natürlich wegen Gehalt und vor allem wegen der Homeoffice-Regelung vom Acker,
gibt aber ein paar andere Sachen, die mir auch noch auf den Keks gegangen sind, aber auch,
weil man irgendwie sieht, das fährt zunehmend gegen die Wand. Und das ist ja das Problem,
was viele Arbeitgeber dann auch haben, wenn die erstmal in so einer Situation sind. Was sind die
ersten Leute, die abhauen? Das sind meistens Leute, die noch jung sind, relativ jung, ich
meine, ich will nicht sagen, dass ich mit 38 super jung bin und die halt auch relativ schnell was
Neues finden. Die sind als erstes weg. Was eigentlich die Leute sind, die man bräuchte,
dass es ordentlich funktioniert. Und es gibt ja oftmals welche, die kommen auf so glorreiche Ideen,
wie wir brauchen weniger Personal, also lass mal irgendeine tolle Personalabbauaktion machen. Jeder,
der freiwillig kündigt, bekommt eine dicke Abfindung. Was bleibt am Ende übrig?
Du hast am Ende übrig einen Haufen unfähiger Leute, die nichts anderes finden oder irgendwie
keinen Bock haben, sich nach was anderem umzugucken, mit denen du nichts anfangen kannst. Ausnahmen
bestätigen die Regel. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch wirklich fähige Leute bei uns, die sind
noch fauler als ich, sich was Neues zu suchen. Ich bin schon mega faul gewesen, Leute. Hätte
ich, also ich habe ja wirklich Glück gehabt, hätte ich nicht mich auf Twitch ausgekotzt,
in den Videos ausgekotzt, auf YouTube, hätte ich wahrscheinlich jetzt keinen neuen Job.
Weil ich wurde ja immer angeschrieben von, also von den Firmen über Umwege. Ich habe mich ja
da gar nicht wirklich beworben, weil ich gesehen habe, auf der Homepage ist was, da bewirbst du
dich jetzt. Also das war rein, weil ich öffentlich geflamed habe, habe ich Anfragen gekriegt. Ja,
und einer ist es jetzt auch geworden, weil ich bin mega faul, was sowas angeht. Aber ganz im
Ernst, ich hätte wahrscheinlich nicht nach einer neuen Stelle gesucht, hätten sie es mit unserer
Homeoffice-Regelung nicht so verkackt. Das war wirklich der Knackpunkt, wo ich dann gesagt habe,
hey, Gehalt ist schon nicht so geil, gibt andere Sachen, die mir auf den Keks gehen, aber das hat
jetzt so das Fass zum Überlaufen gebracht. Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf und jetzt suche ich mir was
anderes. Und jetzt ist auch Ende Gelände. Kündigung ist raus, Kündigung ist unterschrieben, eingereicht,
neuer Vertrag ist unterschrieben, eingeschmissen. Ich habe auch schon die Bestätigung bekommen,
dass er da ist. Jo. Eine Kantine haben wir auch, das wird zum Beispiel null erwähnt in der Stellenanzeige,
das würde ich sofort da reinschreiben, weil Kantine im Haus ist eines der besten Sachen,
die du haben kannst, wenn du wirklich mal vor Ort bist, weil da musst du nicht raus. Es ist meistens
subventioniert, wenn nicht sogar ganz umsonst. Am meisten ist es subventioniert, sodass du dich
nicht dumm und dämlich bezahlst. Und es ist halt einfach auch näher. Du bist keine Stunde unterwegs,
sondern plus 20 Minuten, 30 Minuten. Und die musst du eh nehmen, weil ab, glaub,
sechs Stunden Arbeitszeit musst du ja eine halbe Stunde Pause machen. Es ist ja nicht direkt
Konkurrenz. Es ist halt auch Frankfurter Finanzbranche. Jo. Aber so ziemlich alles in der Ecke ist
Frankfurter Finanzbranche. Ja, richtig 3 hat. Hab morgen mündliche Abschlussprüfung für den
FISE noch paar Tipps. Hab ich irgendwelche Fragen überlesen? Hast du noch ein paar Tipps? Mündliche
Abschlussprüfung. Mir läuft die Nase. Was hast du für ein Projekt gemacht? Kannst du sagen,
wie es heißt? Du musst ja nicht eins zu eins hier schreiben, sondern nur so grob, was es ist. Wobei
ich der Titel des Projektes interessieren würde. Sind da noch Jobs offen? Ja, die suchen immer
Leute. Es geht nicht um meinen Job. Es geht um den Job in unserem Operations Center mit Schichtarbeit
und Nachtzuschlag und alles. Darum ging es, nicht bei mir. Wie gesagt, in unserem Operations Center
die verdienen ungefähr 85k im Jahr. Das ist allerdings halt inklusive Nachtzuschlag,
Sonntagsarbeitzuschlag, Feiertage und Nacht und sowas. Und davon bleibt aber halt am Ende noch
ein bisschen mehr übrig, weil die auf viele Zuschläge nicht so viel Steuern bezahlen müssen.
Das glaube ich dir nicht. Swipes, gibäde mich nicht. Das ist nicht dein Abschlussprojekt.
Und wenn das doch dein Abschlussprojekt ist, wie bist du da drauf gekommen?
Also warum ich frage ist, ich glaube dir einfach mal, dass das wirklich dein Projekt ist oder du
mich gibäden willst, weil ich habe das auch schon öfters erzählt. Mein Abschlussprojekt war mehr
oder weniger exakt das gleiche. Nur dass ich es nicht Evaluierung einer VPN-Lösung genannt habe,
sondern ich glaube mein Abschlussprojekt hieß Evaluierung einer Standort-Kopplung oder sowas.
Ja, also ich habe mehr oder weniger exakt das gleiche gemacht. Ich könnte mal in einem Video,
falls ich, oh das habe ich glaube ich nicht mehr. Ich könnte meine Abschlussdoku mal zeigen in einem
Video, aber die habe ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Ja, also wir haben mehr oder weniger das
gleiche Projekt gemacht. Naja, meine Abschlussprüfung lief ja nicht so gut. Genau,
weil sie mich am Morgen des Prüfungstages angerufen haben, ich wäre durchgefallen.
Also was gibt es für einen Tipp für die Abschlussprüfung mündlich? Also das lief
bei mir total einfach. Also ich habe meinen Zeug erzählt, die haben mich nichts gefragt und
dann war ich durch. Aber das muss nicht immer so sein. Kommt natürlich darauf an,
wie man da so erwischt. Also ich denke, man sollte vorbereitet sein drauf, gerade wenn es um VPN geht,
dass sie dich durchaus auch mal zu DCP und Netzwerkgrundlagen fragen, weil die Prüfer
haben ja nicht unbedingt immer Ahnung von dem, was man da macht. Und wenn du da jetzt ein Prüfer
sitzen hast, der jetzt nur Ahnung von Windows Active Directory hat, versucht er manchmal so den Bogen
zu spannen zu wie sieht das im Active Directory aus, weil er halt sonst nichts weiß, nichts dazu
sagen kann. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass sie dir teilweise sehr weird, komische Fragen stellen.
Aber ansonsten guck, dass du mit der Zeit hinkommst. Das ist wahrscheinlich das Allerwichtigste,
dass du mit deiner Zeit halbwegs hinkommst. Also du hast wahrscheinlich deine Präsentation auch
schon ein bisschen geübt, hoffe ich. Wäre auf jeden Fall sinnvoll. Ja, Beamer dabei haben,
ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt. Ich habe auch mein eigenes mitgenommen, obwohl die einen da
hatten. Aber ich glaube mittlerweile stellen die einen.
Tja, da wäre es sinnvoll gewesen, du hättest in deiner Doku irgendwas drinne zur Funktionsweise
der Firewall. Im Zweifelsfall auch mit Link auf die Herstellerseite, weil dann hättest du einfach
sagen können, ja das ist irgendwie neue Funktion und hier in der Quellenangabe ist das genauer
erklärt. Das ist so, weil die können ja nicht random einfach sagen, es stimmt nicht. Wenn
natürlich einfach nur was gesagt wird, ohne dass man es irgendwie pauschal belegen kann,
ist natürlich schwierig, gerade wenn das irgendwas Neues ist, weil viele Leute, die in der Prüfungsausschuss
sitzen, haben jetzt vielleicht mit Firewall-Themen, die vor 20 Jahren was zu tun gehabt. Da hat sich
Firewall-Technik ja schon einiges getan. Die können ja mittlerweile sogar verschlüsselten
Traffic untersuchen, allerdings nicht so schlimm, wie es sich anhört. Die können aber anhand,
also manche Firewalls können das, ob das die kann, weiß ich nicht, die können anhand der
Muster, die man in verschlüsselndem Traffic sieht, so in welchem Intervall kommen Pakete,
was ist so Burst-Übertragungsrate und so. Also sprich, wie die Pakete von außen aussehen oder
wie der Trafficfluss von außen aussieht, können die ungefähr schon sagen, was da wohl drin ist.
Ist eigentlich ziemlich, ziemlich sixhead. Ich meine, es ist ja logisch. Guck ich ein YouTube-Video
über HTTPS, ist das ganz anderer Verlauf von meinem Traffic und Verhalten von meinem Traffic,
wie wenn ich jetzt Instant-Messaging mache oder sowas. Ist ja logisch. Also man kann da schon,
auch wenn man einfach nur den Traffic von außen sich anguckt, ein bisschen analysieren,
was ist das wohl. Und das kann Application Firewalls heute auch.
SSL entschlüsseln können die Dinger ja auch nicht. SSL entschlüsseln können die Dinger nur,
wenn du Zertifikate, also Custom CAS oder irgendwie sowas, Custom Trust Zeug hast.
Gibt ja manche Unternehmen, die kommen auf so blöde Ideen, wie alle müssen über einen
ausgehenden Proxy und dort machen wir SSL auf und gucken rein und das ist halt, das ist halt cringe.
Funktioniert ja auch nur, wenn die Clients unter deiner Kontrolle sind, weil du ja Zertifikate
hinterlegen musst. Klappt das ja nicht. Sonst würde ja SSL, wenn das gehen würde einfach so,
würde ja SSL unsinnig sein. Wie komme ich an die Stellenausschreibung ohne Leak? Gar nicht.
Ich kann die Stellenausschreibung nicht schicken ohne Leak.
Echt geht dann, geht dann die Werbung auch schneller?
Du musst den Beamer mitnehmen, okay. Wie gesagt, also falls du es noch nicht gemacht hast,
das wichtigste ist, dass du bei deiner Zeit hin, also dass du siehst, dass du deine Präsentation
ein bisschen geübt hast, dass ich das flüssig anhöre, dass ich es so anhöre, dass du Ahnung
wovon du redest, was man prinzipiell haben sollte, weil die können dich auch was zu fragen und
du weißt eigentlich, dass du mit der Zeit hinkommst. Ich hoffe, du hast schon im Vorfeld ein bisschen
geübt. Du hast mehr als genug geübt, okay nice. Ich hoffe nicht nur alleine, sondern auch mal,
wenn einer vor dir hockt, weil es ist ganz was anderes, wenn man sich das alleine überlegt,
als wenn mal jemand vor einem sitzt und es dann halbwegs kompetent wirken soll. Mit viel
Ausbelehrung, dann kann wahrscheinlich nichts mehr großartig schief gehen.
Allerdings eine Sache würde ich tatsächlich sagen, ich weiß nicht in wie weit die dir
reingeredet haben, wie du was sagen sollst, wie du was machen sollst. Also ich habe eine Sache gemerkt,
immer wenn man mal so Probe präsentiert, mal angenommen, du zeigst eine Präsentation
drei verschiedenen Leuten, die sagen dir drei verschiedene Sachen zu. Am Ende muss man immer
noch gucken, dass man sich selbst wohlfühlt, wie man die Sache präsentiert. Also selbst,
wenn du jetzt einen hast, der dir erzählt, ah an der Stelle musst du so sagen, an der Stelle würde
ich das anders machen, das wäre schön und gut, wenn er das anders machen würde, aber es muss
dir trotzdem immer noch authentisch von den Lippen kommen. Das heißt, wenn du deine Präsentation so
sehr umbaust zu dem, was jemand anderes für gut hält, muss deine Präsentation dadurch nicht
besser werden. Auch wenn er da gute Gründe für hat, es muss immer noch zu einem passen, wie man das sagt.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Also da gucken wir uns mal ein paar Videos an. Hab ich sonst noch
irgendwas wichtiges verpasst? Wir gucken mal kurz GitHub Trends. Gucken wir auch einmal die
Woche rein, was es da so neues gibt. Was ist hier Trending? Nicht Today. Weak. China-Chinesen Zeug
bestimmt wieder Hacking Tools. Ganz viel AI Zeug. China-Chinesen Kram. China-Chinesen Kram.
Lens. Ok, das kenne ich. Genau, Kubernetes Zeug. Hier habe ich anhand des Namens schon keine Ahnung,
was es sein soll. Hybrid Streaming Data Frame Library. Leute, hat irgendjemand einen Plan,
was die mir damit sagen wollen? Eine Hybrid Streaming Data Frame Library. Kein Plastenschimmer,
was das sein soll. I am written in Rust, blazingly fast. Next Gen Knowledge Base System. Ich müsste
den Bot mal fixen. Was muss ich denn machen? Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich machen muss.
Was soll ich machen, um den Bot zu fixen? Der Bot ist ja nicht von mir. Was muss man dann machen,
um den Bot zu fixen? Neu autorisieren. Und wie mache ich das? Da brauche ich ja irgendeinen Link,
wo ich draufklicken kann und dann wird mich gefragt, möchten Sie das diesem Bot erlauben?
Aber ich brauche irgendeinen Link. Ich weiß nicht, der Bot ist ja nicht von mir. Das muss
der Sebaro machen oder der Patrick muss das machen. Einen von beiden. Die müssen wir mal
da anspannen zu. Next Gen Knowledge Base System. Okay. Meine Augen. Meine Augen, Leute. Warum
habe ich keinen Dark Reader, man? Dark Reader. MonkaS. Das ist schon viel besser. Hast du
über GitHub Trends schon Sachen gefunden? Ja, ja. Du musst jetzt aber drüber nachdenken,
was? Aber habe ich schon. Okay, ein Knowledge Base System. Guck ich mir nachher mal an. Es
ist nicht so, als müsste man sich da sofort. Kann man bot? Ganz wichtig. Kann man bot ohne
BK. Ach, das ist so für Teams, oder? Collaborative Knowledge Base. Okay, das ist nicht so spannend.
Dann haben wir hier irgendwie ein Hybrid Streaming Data Frame Library. Ich weiß nicht, was es
sein soll. Das ist mittlerweile so abgenutzt, diese Formulierung schon. Leute, ich habe
legit keinen Plan, was es ist. Hört sich toll an, aber ich weiß nicht, was es sein
soll. Ist das irgendwie so ein Messagepost oder sowas? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es
ist. Ich habe mittlerweile sogar schon Sachen gefunden, die sind in Go oder.NET programmiert,
wo die Leute Placingly Fast geschrieben haben. Ich dachte bloß Rust Projekte können Placingly
Fast sein. So, was können wir uns jetzt mal angucken? Gaben hat ein Bluescreen. Okay,
das ist aber auch schon 20 Jahre her, oder? Okay, 11 Jahre. Mittlerweile erkennst du
ja Gaben so im Bad schon kaum noch. Okay, das Video habe ich schon geguckt. Okay, was
können wir uns dann angucken? Was macht denn eigentlich Level Cap? Kann das Level Cap nicht
mal wieder jebaiten? Gibt es nichts. Kein Level Cap jebait. Kein jebait, gibt nichts.
Wie schauen sich die Videos auf einem 5000 Euro PC? Flüssig. Haben sie auf dem alten
aber auch schon. So, also es muss jetzt irgendwas gehen, was wir uns angucken können. Gebrauchte
Thin Clients im Test. Alles klar. Thin Clients als Alternative zum Raspberry Pi. Na dann,
auf geht's. Guck mal, es ist so ein, ich reg mich so auf über Windows 11. Es ist so dumm.
Guck mal, ich möchte jetzt hier rüber, um den Sound auszumachen. Warum muss ich das
über dieses dämliche Task-Switch-Fenster machen? Das ist so unglaublich dämlich, alter.
Ich werde es das nächste Mal einfach im Chrome aufmachen, dass ich es da drüber, ich installiere
mir einfach noch einen vierten Browser, nur dafür. Das ist so dumm, es ist so umständlich,
so dämlich. Warum ist das überhaupt so? Ich mein, wozu brauche ich diesen Scheißplatz
hier unten überhaupt? Der ist doch frei, man. Man kann den nicht mehr entkoppieren. Nee,
kann man nicht, kann man nicht. Das ist ein Feature, was die neue Windows 11 Taskleiste
nicht unterstützt. Muss man sich mal vorstellen, Alter. Muss man sich wirklich mal vorstellen.
Das war der Angesche für den Sub. Die Highlights von der CES. Was war CES? Consumer Electronics
Show. Jetzt was Gutes bei Windows 11. Da müsste ich jetzt drüber nachdenken, aber ich denke
mal ein paar Sachen sind. So blöd es klingt, Windows 11 ist die einzige Alternative gewesen
für mich. Ich konnte gar nichts anderes verwenden als Windows 11. Sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich
nur Windows 10 verwendet. Windows 11 ist das einzige Betriebssystem von Microsoft, die
meine CPU ordentlich unterstützt. Weil ich habe hier einen 13900K, das bedeutet im Endeffekt,
ich habe glaube acht Performance Cores und zwölf, glaube ich zumindest. Wie viele Kerne
habe ich? Sieht man das irgendwo? Cores 24. Ja, ich habe, ich glaube ich habe acht Performance
Cores und dann 16, 16 Efficiency Cores oder wie das heißt. Und die acht Performance Cores
haben halt Hyperthreading, deswegen sind sie quasi 16. Kommt hin, was ich sage. Und Windows
10 kann das nicht. Der Windows 10 Prozess, Scheduler, CPU Time, Verwaltungstool, Verwaltungsding
im Windows Kernel kann diese CPU Architektur so mit diesen Efficiency Cores und den Performance
Cores kann das erst seit Windows 11. Also ich kann gar nichts anderes nehmen als Windows
11. Sind diese 10 Euro Windows Lizenz Keys legal? Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wo
man die kauft, aber prinzipiell, wenn das nicht als Scam erkennbar ist oder offensichtlich
shady, dann muss man ja von ausgehen können, dass das legal ist. Gibt ja, gibt ja sogar
beim Lidl teilweise Lizenzen für 10 Euro, also warum sollte man davon ausgehen, dass
es nicht legit ist? Würde deine Hardware unter Linux funktionieren? Ja. Jaja, das würde
unter Linux besser funktionieren als unter Windows 10. Linux funktioniert wunderbar mit
den neuen Cores. Also ein halbwegs modernes. Das mache ich nicht. Erstens macht es ja wenig
Sinn, Windows 10 in Windows 11 zu integrieren. Außerdem ist es nach jedem Update wieder
weg und wer weiß nicht, wie sich das in Zukunft verhält, wenn man sowas installiert hat. Ne,
ne, das werde ich mir nicht draufhauen. Sollte Windows 10 nicht das letzte Windows sein,
das sagt Microsoft, das haben sie nie behauptet. Microsoft sagt es stimmt nicht, dass sie
das gesagt haben. Es kann auch durchaus sein, dass es nie jemand über einen offiziellen
Kanal von Microsoft gesagt hat, aber Microsoft hat es zumindest auch nicht bestritten. Microsoft
hat das gerne wahrscheinlich so so hingenommen zur damaligen Zeit. Ja, ich erinnere mich,
da war was. Wie findest du eigentlich 32 zu 9 Monitore? Also ich habe auf der Arbeit
einen großen Curved Monitor. Ich weiß nicht, ob der 32 zu 9 ist. Das kann ich dir nicht
sagen. Das ist quasi ungefähr so wie zwei 16 zu 9 Bildschirme nebeneinander. Also ja,
31 zu 9 dann im Endeffekt. Also. Das ist okay, aber ich persönlich bevorzuge zwei Bildschirme.
Ich habe auch zwei Bildschirme, ich habe hier zwei 16 zu 9 Bildschirme nebeneinander stehen.
Einen alten ISO Monitor habe ich hier stehen, den habe ich schon wirklich ganz ganz lang.
Der ist aber auch kalibriert und auf dem stimmen auch die Farben und sowas. Und hier rechts
den fürs zum da den ihr auch hier seht zum Spielen mit 240 Hertz. Wobei der hier also
ich da wo ich mit der Maus rum wackele, ihr seht den Monitor natürlich nicht von außen.
Den werde ich wahrscheinlich ablösen durch einen OLED Bildschirm, wenn es denn dann ein
bisschen mehr OLED Bildschirme gibt, die nicht so groß sind und die 240 Hertz haben. Weil
240 Hertz in Kombination mit OLED Technologie ist natürlich schon fast ein CRT. Also mehr
werde ich dann die nächsten Jahre über wahrscheinlich echt nicht brauchen. Okay, also gucken wir
uns jetzt mal an, ob man mit den Clients einen Raspberry Pi ersetzen kann. Also auf geht's.
Ach er wieder. Das ist ja nichts neues. Auf eBay gibt es schon lange für ein Apple und
i alte Computer, die auch leistungstechnisch durchaus okay sind. Das Problem bei alten
Kisten ist, also zumindest bei den größeren alten Kisten ist, es kaufen sich ja Leute
beispielsweise alte Rack Server und sowas. Die sind halt laut und die verbrauchen meistens
abfuck viel Strom. Bei Synth Clients kann das ganze natürlich schon wieder anders aussehen.
Ich denke mal, da bewegen wir uns auf jeden Fall unter 20 Watt. Also ein Raspberry Pi
vier unter Volllast kann ja auch bis zu zehn Watt oder so verbrauchen, aber da musste das
Ding schon wirklich komplett auslasten. Ja, das LG Ding kenne ich. Auf den LG, falls das
der ist, den ich mir angeguckt habe, habe ich auch schon, ja das ist der. Das ist aber
der einzige, den es zum Zeitpunkt, wo ich geguckt habe, angekündigt war. Noch gibt
es den da noch nicht mal. Ich warte erst mal, bis es ein bisschen mehr gibt. Den kenne
ich, das ist aber auch der einzige. Warum ist da unten die Windows-Taskleiste? Leute,
was ist das da? Was ist das da? Warum ist da eine Taskleiste? Alter, was ist das? Windows,
Mann. Alter, hier geht das Firefox-Beste. Und das ist jetzt nicht so ein schön gerechneter
Preis, wo man in der Realität noch super viel Zeug dazukaufen muss. Das ist wirklich
inklusive Netzteilgehäuse und Datenträger. Ihr könnt euch das wahrscheinlich schon denken.
Geht um gebrauchte sogenannte Sim-Clients, die ja schon seit längerem ziemlich angesagt
sind. Die sind wirklich ziemlich dünn. Und wirklich eine super Alternative zu Raspberry
Pi und Coda. Das Problem, eigentlich bräuchte man ja gar keine Alternative zum Raspberry
Pi in diesem Space, wo es den Raspberry Pi gibt. Das Problem ist nur, dass es aktuell
keine Raspberry Pies gibt. Und wenn es welche gibt, abfuckteuer, dass es das am Endeffekt
auch nicht mehr wert ist. Das bies ja bekanntlich schon seit Monaten nicht oder sehr schlecht.
Warum eigentlich? Ich habe mir für dieses Video zwei Sim-Clients besorgt. Einmal den
HP T620 für 30€ inklusive Versand und einmal den Dell Wwise 5070 inklusive Versand. Also
irgendwie sieht der Dell älter aus, oder? Was meint ihr? Welche Kiste ist aktueller?
Von der Hardware her? Der Dell oder der HP? Also ich würde sagen, der HP ist deutlich
aktueller von der Optik her und den blauen USB-Ports schon. Der hier hat ja wahrscheinlich nur
normale USB-Ports. Was, der Dell ist wirklich neuer? Das Ding hier sieht viel moderner aus.
Ach, das ist ein USB-C. Hab ich gar nicht gesehen. Ok Leute, ihr habt Recht. Das Ding ist neuer.
Das USB-C ist eindeutig neuer. An der Berufsschule braucht jeder einen Raspberry Pi. Wie? Man
macht mal was Sinnvolles in der Berufsschule. 97€. Ich habe die beiden lüfterlosen Computer,
eine Spielkonsole, Home Server und Linux Desktop getestet. Bleibt dran. Na gut, für einen Desktop-Betrieb
würde ich das nicht verwenden. Lieber Ecken, liebe Internet-Surfer. Dieses Intro ist sauber.
Herzlich willkommen hier bei... Also Desktop würde ich den Kram nicht verwenden. Wozu? Dieses
Video wird gesponsert von NordVPN. Ihr könnt mit NordVPN... Jetzt fängt die CT schon an mit
NordVPN, Mann. Ah, ich hab noch was wichtiges. Wir suchen immer noch Leute zur Verstärkung des...
Also, dass ich ein Fan von Raspis bin, das dürftet ihr inzwischen mitbekommen haben. Zu Raspis haben wir
hier bei 3003 ja schon etliche Videos gemacht. Allerdings haben ganz viele von euch bei den
letzten Videos gesagt, ah, Raspis, die sind doch komplett over. Wir coolen Nerds sind längst auf
gebrauchten Synth-Client unterwegs und bauen damit unsere Plex-Server. Das stimmt, das stimmt ja.
Insofern, letztens hatten wir auch Leute im Stream, die haben gesagt, Max, Raspberry Pi outdated,
Synth-Client sind angesagt. Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern? Chat, der Chat war wieder komplett der
Zeit voraus. Chat einfach way too high IQ. Ich muss zugeben, dass mich das zuerst etwas irritiert hat,
weil Synth-Client ja nun gerade per Definition das Gegenteil von Servern sind. Also Synth-Client
sind ja dafür da, möglichst klein und sparsam zu sein, weil die Software halt nicht auf den
Clients laufen. Gut, aber wenn man es im Raspberry Pi vergleicht, ist es natürlich trotzdem, in den
ganzen Synth-Client sind zu 99 Prozent ganz normale x86 64 Hardware drin, die ja meistens
eh schon ein bisschen performanter ist, oder was heißt ein bisschen, eine ganze Ecke performanter
ist als ein Raspberry Pi. Dafür meistens aber auch ein bisschen mehr Stromverbrauch. Dann auf
Servern, also die Synth-Client zapfen einfach nur die Server an. Aber wenn ihr das sagt, dann muss
ich das natürlich ausprobieren. Wo liegt dann das OS? Das kommt darauf an, wie man es macht,
aber solche Synth-Client werden ganz gerne mit Citrix zusammen in Verbindung benutzt.
Das sieht dann, habe ich keine Ahnung von, habe ich noch nie gemacht, aber ich hoffe die halt,
ich dachte die hatten irgendwie mal ein Bildchen von. Ja, so sieht das dann ungefähr aus. Du hast
dann dein Citrix Server und hast dann ein Synth-Client und kriegst dann die Ausgabe. Machen einige. Tja,
wie sinnvoll das ist, sei mal dahingestellt. Ich bin da kein großer Fan von Citrix. Aber okay,
kann man machen. Hast du schon die Citrix Single Sign-On Schwäche gesehen? Nein. Das macht den
privaten Gebrauch keinen Sinn. Das ist korrekt. Deswegen will er es ja auch nicht so verwenden,
sondern er will da ganz normal Linux draufhauen. Oder vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, hat es glaube
ich auch nicht gesagt, aber doch hat er gesagt. Wir haben also zwei gebrauchte Synth-Clients bestellt
und der erste ist der HPT620, den man wirklich an sehr vielen Ecken im Internet hinterher geworfen
bekommt. So zwischen 20 und 40 Euro. Das ist ja nichts. Und da drin steckt der Dual-Core-Prozessor
AMD GX217A. Ach der! Alter, das ist aber uralt das Ding. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, aus welcher
Generation das ist, aber das ist ja uralt. Das ist noch weit, weit, weit vor Ryzen und Epic und so.
Und diese Generation, das ist noch irgendwie Bulldozer oder sowas. Das ist uralt, Alter.
Gigahertz-Tacted und schon 2013 vorgestellt wurde. Also schon ziemlich antik. In der von mir
getesteten Version stecken vier Gigabyte RAM drin und eine 16 Gigabyte SSD. Mein zweiter
sind klein. Okay, 16G SSD wird knapp, aber das ist wahrscheinlich kein Problem, weil man kann
über USB einfach was reinstecken oder man könnte wahrscheinlich auch intern da bestimmt noch
irgendwie so eine flache SSD mit reinmogeln. Das ist ein Dell Wyze 5070, den ihr so ungefähr ab
80 Euro bekommt und da steckt ein Quad-Core-Chip drin und zwar ein Intel Celeron J41. Der ist gut.
Das ist ein Dual-Core-Chip. Nee, Quad-Core ist das. Okay, das ist gut. Darauf hatte ich jetzt auch zwei
Jahre lang einen Low-Power-Server bei mir laufen, einen Low-Power NAS, was ich dann ersetzt habe
durch diesen HP Micro-Server. Aber ja, die Plattform ist gut. 5 mit 1,5 Gigahertz. Das ist okay.
Das ist aber okay. In meinem Testgerät sind 8 Gigabyte RAM und 64 Gigabyte Flash drin. Und ganz
wichtig übrigens, das sind x86 CPUs, also PC Standardarchitektur. Dein Odroid H2,
das ist die gleiche Plattform. Das ist die gleiche Plattform, die da drin ist. Nicht die von Raspis
genutzte ARM-Architektur. Und 80 Euro sind übrigens immer noch im Raspi-Preisbereich. Wenn ihr viel
Glück habt, dann bekommt ihr einen blanken Raspi 4 mit 2 Gigabyte für 50 Euro. Die Dinger sind
maßlos überteuert gerade. Und da seid ihr schnell auf 80 Euro. So und wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
äh, Thin Clients, nutzen die nicht immer so komische Betriebssysteme mit so komischer
Terminal-Software und irgendwelchen Sternen... Ja, standardmäßig schon, aber man kann ja Linux
drauf installieren. Ja, ja, ja, das ist korrekt. Auf beiden meinen Thin Clients hier war Windows
Embedded bzw. Windows IoT, also ein Windows, was man so zudängeln kann, dass man damit wirklich
ausschließlich bestimmte Sachen machen kann. Eines der Windows hatte tatsächlich keinerlei
Dateizugriff. Also ich konnte nicht mal auf den eigenen Download- oder Dokumenteordner zugreifen.
Aber ist ja auch egal, da, wo wir hinwollen, brauchen wir eh keinen... Das klappt bei mir
manchmal auch nicht. Und es ist kein Embedded Windows. Windows, das ist ja eine wichtige
3003-Weisheit. Je langsamer ein Rechner, desto mehr will man Linux haben. Dazu haben wir schon
mal ein Video gemacht. Also weg, weg, weg mit Windows. Aber das ist leichter gesagt als getan.
Weg mit Windows sehe ich auch so. Und beide Thin Clients, nicht von USB-Datenträgern,
da muss man erst in die BIOS-Einstellung. Ja, aber wie? Tatsächlich wusste ich von beiden
Geräten, welche Taste man fürs BIOS drücken muss und habe das aber mit so durchgängigen
Hämmern auf die jeweilige...
Ist das ein IBM-Tastaturnachbau?
...Taste, nicht im Moment. Ja, man muss die im richtigen Moment drücken, und zwar kurz bevor
das Boot-Logo verschwindet. Und zwar bei dem HPT620 ist das die F10-Taste, beim Dell-Wise die F2-Taste.
Wenn ihr dann im BIOS seid, müsst ihr bei Boot-Sequence auf den Eintrag gehen...
Hui! Ein GUI-BIOS!
...wo was von USB steht und diesen mit den Pfeilen ganz nach oben schieben. So sieht das
bei Dell aus und so bei HP.
Ja, das ist ein gutes BIOS! Tastatur-Only! Blau auf blau mit grau! Das ist so, so sieht
das BIOS aus, man!
...buten die Teile eurer Installation...
Ich weiß, dass das bei Dell schon ewig so aussieht. Ich hab daheim hier... Moment. Hab ich daheim
einen Dell? Nee, HP hab ich daheim. Aber da sieht's genauso aus. Und auf der Arbeit haben
wir einen Dell. Sogar da sieht das so aus. Es sieht sogar so aus, wenn man eine Firmware-Update-CD
einlegt. Oder? Stick?
...Beta-Anträger. Und ganz kurz dazu, wie ihr sowas herstellt. Wenn ihr zum Beispiel
Ubuntu installieren wollt, holt ihr euch auf...
Leute, Leute, Leute.
...Giubante!
Wenn schon, muss das korrekt auf die coole Art und Weise ausgesprochen werden.
...auf der Download-Seite von Ubuntu die ISO-Datei und schreibt die mit der Software Balena Etcher,
die gibt's für Windows, Mac OS und...
Etcher kann übrigens keine Windows-ISOs erstellen, haben wir letztens festgestellt.
Und schon könnt ihr davon booten.
Und wenn wir jetzt sowieso schon von Ubuntu sprechen, dann installieren wir das so gleich
mal. Funktioniert absolut problemlos. Und um die Schwupptizität zu checken, nutze ich
gern den...
Was?
...so gleich mal. Funktioniert absolut problemlos. Und um die Schwupptizität zu checken, nutze
ich gern den Browser-Benchmark Speedometer, der versucht abzubilden, wie schnell sich
Websites anfühlen auf diesen Rechnern. Und ich hab auf allen Rechnern...
Okay, das muss ich jetzt auch mal ausprobieren. Wie heißt das? Bench?
Nee, wie heißt das was? Das kenn ich gar nicht, die Seite.
Äh, Sekunde. Wie heißt das Ding?
BrowserBench.org
Benchometer. Bam.
Alter, da kriegst du... da kriegst du... da muss man Epilepsiewarnung aussprechen
vorher.
Okay, gleich ist er durch.
Am Ende kommt Rick Astley, ja. Okay, Runs pro Minute 247.
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Der Tacho geht nur bis 140, okay, also ist das anscheinend ganz gut, alles klar.
Aber, ich mein, wenn's auf dem PC nicht gut ist, dann ist es nirgendswo gut, oder?
Was schnelleres kannst du dir aktuell nicht kaufen, als was ich hier stehen habe.
Ich hab wie viel? 240? Und der eine hat 14,5? Okay, jetzt sind mein Rechner noch ein bisschen
schneller.
Ja, der Raspberry Pi. Deswegen verstehe ich auch nicht, warum manche Leute wirklich
einen Raspberry Pi als... ja, den kann man doch auch als Desktop-Ersatz für die Oma
verwenden.
Nee, Desktop auf dem Raspberry Pi, das ist so ein Ding. Ja, das mag vielleicht sein,
wenn man das irgendwie haben möchte für den... keine Ahnung, als GUI am 3D-Drucker oder
sowas.
Ja, okay, irgendwo meinetwegen. Aber arbeiten damit will doch keiner.
Mark setzt sich der Raspberry Pi 4 vor den HP Thin Client und der Dell Wwise erzielt
das beste Resultat. Also mein persönliches Gefühl ist, dass ich den Dell Wwise 5070 als
täglichen Arbeitsrechner mit Ubuntu nutzen könnte, ohne völlig durchzudrehen. Der Raspberry
Pi 4 mit Raspberry Pi OS ging ja auch noch so gerade, aber der HP T620 fühlt sich wirklich
mit Ubuntu zu träger an.
Nee, das will man nicht. Alter, das schläft ja fast ein.
Desktop ist ja eh nur ein Randthema. Viel mehr Leute wollen sich ja billige Home-Server
bauen.
Genau, weil Bilder drauf kann man sagen. Desktop-Anwendung, dafür kauft man sich das
ja auch nicht.
So habe ich auf den Thin Client Open Media Vault installiert. Das ist eine NAS-Software,
die ich sehr praktisch finde. Damit kann man auf USB-Festplatten oder SSDs, die an den
Thin Client angeschlossen sind, übersetzen.
Ich mag Open Media Vault nicht. Also immer, wenn ich es mir angeguckt habe, weiß nicht,
ich habe mir das nie zugesagt. Ich hatte noch nie einen Anwendungsfall, wo ich gesagt hätte,
oh ja, dafür nehme ich jetzt Open Media Vault.
Ja und obendrein habe ich auch noch Plex als Film- und Serien-Server installiert.
Okay, habe ich auch nicht.
Warum das super ist, dazu gibt es hier ein Video. Open Media Vault gibt es als eigene
Linux ISO.
Ich habe keine lokalen Filme mehr.
Also einfach wieder auf den USB-Datenträger booten und auf installieren klicken. Die Installation
geht wirklich straight forward. Einfach immer Return drücken und dann hier den richtigen
Datenträger auswählen und zack ist das Ding auf der internen SSD installiert. Und gleich
schon mal einen riesen Vorteil gefunden gegenüber der Raspi-Version bei der x86-Film-Film.
Leute, meine Frage, es konnte mir bis jetzt noch niemand und ich habe es auch im Stream
schon ein paar Mal gefragt und irgendwie konnte mir das keiner zufrieden stellen beantworten.
Also, waren alle die Plex oder Jellyfin oder sonst was bei sich lokal betreiben? Warum
habt ihr das? Also habt ihr irgendwie eine riesen lokale Sammlung aus Filmen und Serien
auf Terabyte-weise rumliegen, die ihr damit indiziert und ab und zu mal wieder streamt
oder was ist euer Anwendungsfall dafür? Warum habt ihr das?
Weil ich sehe für mich überhaupt keinen Anwendungsfall. Oder gibt es dort irgendwelche Plugins? Oder
gibt es dafür irgendwelche Torrent-Plugins, wo die Leute dann im Hintergrund über VPN
oder was macht ihr damit? Also, alles klar. Okay, ja, dann verstehe ich, was ihr damit
macht. Okay, okay. Weil es ist bei mir halt so, ich habe gar keine Filme mehr lokal.
Also, wenn ich mir einen Film angucke, dann streame ich den von Amazon oder von Netflix
oder ich gucke YouTube, Twitch, aber ich habe keine Filme mehr lokal liegen.
Und was ist Medusa? Weil es jemand geschrieben hat. Ist das ein Ayayara-Plugin? Das wollen
wir uns hier dann natürlich nicht genauer besprechen. Ich habe keine Ahnung davon,
aber ich frage euch nur. Weil irgendjemand geschrieben hat, er benutze das mit Medusa.
Was ist das? Ist das irgendwas, wo man sich Sicherheitskopien von Serien oder was? Das
finden nur Leute schlimm, die im Freenas Forum sind und dort auf dicken Wacker machen. Ansonsten
ist es überhaupt nicht schlimm, Chunas zu virtualisieren. Das ist genauso, wie die Leute,
die sagen, du darfst ZFS nur und ausschließlich mit ECC-RAM betreiben. Würdest du dir ein
Auto drücken, wenn es möglich wäre? Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich wahrscheinlich
Jahre dafür brauchen würde mit meinem kleinen 3D-Drucker. Also wahrscheinlich nicht. Chunas
Fanboy. Sowas gibt es wirklich? Es gibt Chunas Fanboys. Also nicht, dass Chunas was schlechtes
wäre, aber ich hätte es nicht gedacht, dass es so bekannt ist und dass es Mainstream-Stuff
von Fanboys gibt. Chunas Fanboys, nicht schlecht. Na gut, ich meine es gibt ja mittlerweile Merchandise
Stores für alles, außer für mich. Ich habe keine. Es gibt keine Kekse und es gibt keine
T-Shirts und es gibt keine Wubblors Sachen. Es gibt nichts. C++ Fanboys, die gibt es tatsächlich
auch. Die trifft man auf Stack Overflow manchmal. Und ich frage mich immer, was mit den Leuten
los ist. Also ein Rust-T-Shirt würde ich auch anziehen. Placingly fast, written in Rust.
Das sollten mal bei den nächsten Olympischen Spielen die ganzen 100-Meter-Läufer einfach
ein T-Shirt anziehen, vor vorne drauf den Sponsor, Placingly fast und hinten steht dann
drauf written in Rust. Das versteht dann aber keiner. Das ist nicht Mainstream-tauglich.
VGA Fanboy, also ich bin Displayport Fanboy. VGA, ich habe letztens bei mir hier alles
mögliche aufgeräumt an alten Kabeln und sonst was Leute. Ich hatte so viele unsinnige
Adapter- und VGA-Kabel und haste nicht gesehen. Das Video ist doch nicht mal aufgenommen.
Weißt du, wie man in Zweltkit beim ersten Start zu einer spezifischen Route routen kann?
Ne, weil seit der Routing-Umstellung habe ich mit Zweltkit nichts mehr gemacht. Man kann
bestimmt nicht die Fault-Route setzen. Ok, gucken wir mal weiter. Viel geschwätzt, aber
auch ein Media-Vault.
Ja, und wie läuft denn nun der Heim-Server auf den Thimplines? Da war ich erstaunt,
nämlich super. Sogar mit dem total lahmen HP-Dualcore konnte ich an die mit USB angeschlossene
SSD über Samba, über das Netzwerk, mit ungefähr 110 MB die Sekunde. Aber nur ohne Festplatten-Verschlüsselung
gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus. Auf dem Dualcore. Also mit Festplatten-Verschlüsselung
ist dann da an der Stelle Schluss. Mehr, das wird er nicht schaffen. Festplatten-Verschlüsselung,
auf dem neueren Quad-Core wird das aber wahrscheinlich ohne Probleme funktionieren. Da hat nämlich
die CPU, glaube ich, sogar schon Krypto-Extensions. Oh, ein BS-Top-User, oder wie das Ding heißt.
Ja, und Plex läuft auch absolut problemlos, aber natürlich nur, wenn er die Video-Daten
unverändert auf das Anzeig-Gerät schieben kann. Transkodieren geht auf der Lahmen-Kiste
nicht so richtig, das ist aber beim Raspi 4 auch nicht anders. Aber der Delphin-Kline,
der kann sogar transkodieren, wenn man den als Plex-Server verwendet. Im Test konnte
der an einem LG-Fernseher Videodateien mit DTS-Ton plus Untertitel abspielen, ruckelfrei.
Das geht mit Raspi 4 und HP-Dualcore nicht. Der Hintergrund ist, dass viele Fernsehersteller
sich die Lizenzkosten für DTS-Ton sparen und deshalb keinen Kodec integriert haben.
Der Videoserver muss den Ton also on the fly umwandeln und dafür ist der Raspi 4 zu langsam,
der Delwise nicht. Super geeignet als Plex-Server. Und was kostet der? Jetzt denkt ihr bestimmt,
auch nur 30 Euro. Aber der Delphin-Kline, der zieht bestimmt auch viel mehr Energie als
ein Raspi. Erstaunlicherweise, nur ein ganz... Wie viel kostet der Del denn?
Und wo steht, welche Rechner er verwendet hat? 80? Ja, okay. Mit einem angeschlossenen USB-Datenträger
sind das bei Del auch nur 5 Watt, wenn der Rechner gerade nix macht. Der Raspi 4 kommt
im Idle auf 4 Watt, der HP-Dualcore auf 7 Watt. Unter Last sind es beim Del 13 Watt,
beim Raspi 10 Watt. Na das geht doch vollkommen klar. Und beim HP 16. Das geht doch vollkommen
klar. Viele Thin-Klines haben SATA-Ports. Aber die Stromversorgung ist nicht für so eine
3,5 Zoll-Platte ausgelegt. Die ganz Großen davon brauchen jetzt noch mehr. Wart da vorne, wart da vorne.
Es ist überhaupt nicht voll. Meine Festplatten sind alle noch leer.
Was erzählt ein OBS da wieder für Zeug?
...auf mehr als viele Thin-Klines unter Last. Zudem braucht man der Adapterkabel und deswegen
habe ich einfach hier fürs Video, weil es einfacher ist, USB-Datenträger verwendet. So,
und jetzt nach dem ganzen Serverzeug nochmal ein bisschen Spaß. Was taugen die Thin-Kline
als Retro-Spielkonsolen? Dafür habe ich die Linux-Distribution BatoSera verwendet,
bei der Emulatoren für alle... BatoSera habe ich auch noch nie gehört....Spielkonsolen
vorinstalliert und vorkonfiguriert sind. BatoSera läuft auch sehr gut komplett von USB-Stick. Man
muss das also nicht installieren. Zum Spielen braucht ihr natürlich ROMs oder Disketten-Images und
die bekommt ihr da drauf, indem ihr mit einem SCP-Kline auf die IP-Adresse der Thin-Kline geht
und als Login-Route und als Passwort Linux eingebt. Das sind die Standardwerte von BatoSera. Die
Dateien liegen unter User-Data-ROMs. Sollen wir vielleicht mal ein ganzes Video mit ein paar mehr...
Natürlich, natürlich nur, nur von eigenen Spielen extrahierte ROMs.
BatoSera machen? Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und liken natürlich und abonnieren
ihr bis dahin. So, jetzt erstmal Controller angeschlossen und losgespielt. Ich bin wirklich
einigermaßen beeindruckt gewesen, weil der Dell Thin-Kline nicht nur die ganzen 8- und 16-Bit-Systeme
packt, sondern auch Spiele neuere Konsolen wie Nintendo Wii oder PS2. Also nicht alle, aber zum
Beispiel die PS2-Version von Tony Hawk 3 lief hier bei mir ganz wunderbar auf dem Dell. Beim HP
Dual Core klappen natürlich nicht so viele Systeme, aber die üblichen verdächtigen C64, NES, SNES,
Mega Drive, PS1 kann man darauf recht problemlos emulieren. Und hey, für 30 Euro inklusive allem,
das ist schon billiger Spaß. Einen HDMI-Ausgang haben die beiden Thin-Klines übrigens nicht,
sondern nur Display-Port. Da braucht ihr also einen Adapter, wenn ihr die an den Fernseher
anschließen wollt. Mein Fazit. Adapter habe ich genug. Ich bin echt überrascht, dass man mit antiken
Thin-Klines so viel machen kann und auch, dass der lahme Dual-Core-HP für Open Media Vault und
Plex ausreicht und genauso einen guten Job macht wie mein Raspi 4. Nur leider hat der HP T620 eine
höhere Leistungsaufnahme als ein Raspi, weshalb... Aber nicht viel. Leider nicht uneingeschränkt.
Aber nicht viel, nicht wirklich viel, oder? Der Dell Wwise 5070 liegt leistungsaufnahmemäßig fast
gleich auf mit dem Raspi 4, also der verbraucht wirklich nur minimal mehr, hat aber signifikant
mehr Leistung. Also, dass der einige Sachen transkodieren kann in Plex, das ist schon
wirklich super, wenn man den als Film- und Serienserver einsetzen will. Ja, und als Retro-Spielkontrolle...
Wieso haben Fernseher keinen Display-Port, sondern HDMI? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da wieder
Anschlusstechnisch läuft. Keine Ahnung. Ich verstehe es auch nicht, warum wir da zwei verschiedene
Sachen wieder haben. Super brauchbar. Und die Umwelt freut sich natürlich auch, wenn wir nicht
immer fabrikneues Zeug shoppen, sondern auch mal einfach was Gebrauchtes. Also guckt euch die
Dinger mal an. Ok, ich kaufe mir jetzt so ein Ding auf Ebay für die Umwelt. Easy. Aber ich
habe überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck für...
Snay, danke schön für den Zapp. Ich habe mir die Hälfte heute vergessen. Jesper, danke für den Zapp, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Poggers. Kann Display-Port auch Audiosignale übertragen? Ja. Demnächst ist eh alles nur
USB-C. So in 10 Jahren gucken wir mal. Das stimmt, er war ein bisschen links im Bild, nicht ganz rechts.
Weird Champ. Oh komm, es gibt ein neues Fireship-Video. Wollen wir uns das angucken? How to actually
learn to code? Seven Roadmaps. In 10 Jahren haben wir dann USB 5 Gen 3.14 oder sowas.
Fireship macht coole Videos. Ja, das gucken wir uns jetzt an. So dumm mit diesem Muten hier,
oft mit diesem umschalten. Version 2. Was? Moment, ich habe jetzt den Anfang nicht gecheckt.
Alter, Windows regt mich auf. Guckt euch das an.
Aber für den Chat alles kein Problem.
Lass mich gerade fangen mit irgendwelchen Webframeboxen an.
Für mich war
Ich finde das witzig, dass er das erzählt, weil ganz ehrlich, wir haben hier auch öfters
ja die Frage, wie fängt man am besten mit Programmieren an oder wie lernt man das
am besten?
Meiste, also was ich den Leuten hauptsächlich immer rate, ist, schnapp dir einen Texteditor
und einen Browser und bastel ein bisschen rum.
Dann siehst du was, die Einstiegshürde ist total niedrig und man kann sich ein bisschen
rantasten, ob das überhaupt was ist für einen, weil viele Leute wollen einfach nur
mal ein bisschen gucken und haben auch gar kein wirkliches Projekt irgendwie im Kopf oder
was, was sie unbedingt machen wollen, bisschen JavaScript, HTML, letztendlich brauchst du
es eh früher oder später, an JavaScript, HTML, CSS kommt doch eh keiner heutzutage
vorbei, außer du bist Cobol-Mainframe-Entwickler, also wir sind Zwelt-Enjoyer im Stream, also
wir sind Zwelt-Enjoyer im Stream, oder man lernt im gleichen Atemzug noch irgendein
ordentliches Backend-Framework, es muss ja nicht unbedingt Express sein, es kann auch
ASP.NET Core sein oder man kann auch was in Go machen oder Spring Boot, meinetwegen wenn
es Java sein soll, wenn das wirklich irgendjemand der Meinung ist, es ist eine gute Idee, aber
ja, es soll auch ganz okay sein, ich persönlich mag ASP.NET Core, dann braucht man nicht
sich mit irgendwelchen komischen Cloud-Services gleich auseinandersetzen, was ich verkehre,
das einfache ist es bestimmt.
Ich mag ja Rails, weil es ist Ruby und Ruby ist eine super Programmiersprache, leider
ist es die letzten Jahre über irgendwie fast bis in die Bedeutungslosigkeit irgendwie
verschwunden, hat noch jemand von euch die Ehre an einem Ruby, also Ruby-Projekt gibt
es ja in der Form kaum noch, an einem Rails-Projekt zu arbeiten, was dann halt auch Ruby ist, also
macht jemand von euch noch, muss er noch Rails machen?
In GitLab ist Ruby, ich weiß, ja, ja, war das für eine Grafik, das war irgendwie der
Programming-Language-Eisberg oder sowas, Schichtbuch auf Arbeit läuft mit Ruby und
Ruby.
somit das bekannteste JavaScript Backend sein soll. Guckt euch mal an, so sieht eine minimale
Express App aus. Jetzt guckt mal, was zehn Jahre vorher es für Ruby schon gegeben hat.
Also ich finde, man erkennt da schon eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit. Also das war tatsächlich eines der
ersten so minimalen Web Frameworks, die mir so einfällt.
Windows! Geh weg!
Ich habe von beiden keine Ahnung, aber alles was ich bisher gesehen habe, lässt mich dazu tendieren.
Ich habe es bis heute nicht verstanden. Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran, weil in Google es
intern auch 580 verschiedene Teams gibt. Warum hat man denn Flutter mit Dart zusammen gemacht?
Warum konnte man nicht Flutter wenigstens, auch wenn ich kein großer Go-Fan bin, aber besser als
noch mal eine extra Sprache, warum konnte man nicht Flutter mit Go oder meinetwegen Flutter mit
JavaScript machen? Warum musste es noch mal eine extra Sprache sein, die man nur dafür verwendet
und sonst für nichts anderes? Das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden. Vielleicht kommt man dahinter,
wenn man das eine Weile verwendet hat. Man hätte Javascript nehmen können, man hätte Go nehmen
können. Irgendwas, aber warum Dart? Warum Dart? Ich verstehe nicht. Oh nee, MAUI ist Müll.
Gtk macht ja keiner, der noch irgendwie bei Besinnung ist.
Wenn man einen bekommt, aktuell ist es ja schwierig.
Another option is to buy an Arduino, which has a microcontroller that can be programmed
with its own C-like language. Along the way there's a ton to learn about circuitry and networking
before you eventually connect your IoT device to the cloud. At that point you'll need to learn
some backend development and protocols like MQTT. Another great place to start learning to code is
by building a game. Modern frameworks like Unity and Godot make it possible for the average
person to develop an awesome game independently. Both frameworks provide an integrated development
environment where you can drag and drop different game elements, then change their behavior with
code. Both game engines are based on the C-Sharp programming language, but Godot also has its own
purpose-built language that's a little easier for beginners. Either way, there's a lot to learn about
about game physics, in addition to 3D modeling, with topics like shaders, meshes, raytracing,
and so on. Luckily, almost everything you need to learn is contained within the game engine,
but there's also a huge ecosystem of third-party assets that you can implement in your own code
so you're not doing everything from scratch. As you gain more experience, you might then check...
Leute, probiert mal das neue Emote aus. Passt jetzt einfach zu gut. Wir müssen jetzt wenigstens
einmal Wupp-Chat einweihen im Chat. Passt einfach zu gut gerade. Non-sup feels Batman,
wie Chain-Lore. Was ist da los? Okay, genug eingeweiht.
Kaggle? Was? Hab ich noch nie was von gehört? Kaggle. Ich kenn K-Kaggle, kenn ich, aber nicht Kaggle.
Fucking Wolfs.
Das stimmt. C kann ja auch nix.
Es ist ein Trial by Fire, welches euch die schlechteste Mutterfuckerin im Gefängnis macht.
In der Wahrheit, wenn ihr diesen Weg geht, werdet ihr wahrscheinlich nur Ihren Arsch gekackt haben.
Aber ich denke, dass jeder Entwickler sich ein bisschen aus dem Gefängnis ausprobieren sollte.
Es wird euch ein stärker, humbler und mehr gut gegründeter Entwickler machen.
Egal, was ihr versucht zu kodieren.
Und wenn ihr wirklich Systems Engineering genießt, könnt ihr eine Sprache wie Rust oder C++ lernen, wenn ihr ein Massakist seid.
Und mit dem haben wir 7 einfache Roadmaps, die ihr in 2023 lernen könntet.
Aber wir haben hier kaum die Oberfläche geschraubt. Es gibt andere Fähigkeiten, die universal sind für fast alle dieser Wege.
Wie wenn ihr Git und GitHub lernen wollt, um die Software Version zu kontrollieren.
Ihr müsst Linux und die Bash-Language für Schaleskripting lernen.
Ihr solltet ein oder andere wissen, wie HTTP...
Wer hat morgen nochmal seine Abschlussprüfung?
... für Schaleskripting.
Ihr solltet ein oder andere...
Also für alle, die morgen Abschlussprüfung haben, Leute.
OSI-Modell, ja?
... über Netzwerken, wie HTTP und DNS funktioniert...
Eigentlich schon für den Zap.
... und wie APIs auf ihnen gebaut werden...
... mit Standards wie REST oder PC und GraphQL.
Die Wahrheit ist, ich bin kein Experte in dieser Sache.
Ich habe so viele Sachen in meinem Gehirn gekrammt, dass wenn ich etwas Neues lerne, etwas auf der anderen Seite fällt.
Es ist normal, sich überwältigt zu fühlen, wenn man zu Codet lernt.
Was ihr tun wollt, ist, wirklich gut zu werden an einer Sache.
Wie wenn ihr ein Top-10% Experte in diesem Gefühl seid.
Es kann sich Jahre dauern, um da zu sein, aber wenn ihr es macht, mögt ihr einen tollen Job für den Rest deiner Leben haben.
Top-10% Experte. Allerdings in allen Spielen.
Das Codet ist eine langweilige Reise. Es gibt keine letzte Destination und es kann extrem frustrierend und schmerzhaft sein.
Aber die Reward für das Schmerzen ist Erfahrung. Und Erfahrung ist das, was dir Geld macht.
Danke fürs Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Der hat dann hier die Auswahl zwischen.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht, ja.
Wo C++? Auch, auch. C++ gibt's auch.
C++ gibt's natürlich auch, ja. C++.
Selbstverständlich.
Richtig nice, so.
So, was, was hat eben einer noch mal von Video geschickt?
Ah, hier. Die Highlights von der CES 2023.
Okay, das meiste, was da vorgestellt wird, ist ja meistens komplett...
Ich komplett unsinnig. Aber gucken wir mal, trotzdem 17 Minuten.
Das passt gut.
Gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Jetzt.
Und die vor allem auch mehr kosten.
Rgb-Lack?
Mehr FPS im Auto.
Ja, wenigstens was Gescheites.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das nicht auch irgendwie so ein Rock-Grepierer wird.
Ich meine, es sind total viele dabei, was Meta angeht.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, wie sich das die nächsten Jahre über entwickelt.
Dann gehen wir direkt rein. Alles Wichtige.
Oder was ich für wichtig halte. Und was angekündigt wurde, bevor ich dieses Video aufgenommen habe.
Meta ist ein Smart-Home-Protokoll.
Was mehrere unterschiedliche Transport-
Protokolle unten drunter unterstützt. Also kannst Meta über Zigbee machen, glaube ich.
Das offizielle Transport-Protokoll von Meta nennt sich, glaube ich, Threat.
Aber es ist quasi ein etwas einheitlicher Smart-Home-Kommunikationsstandard.
So könnte man es, glaube ich, umschreiben.
Inwieweit sich das durchsetzt. Ich bin mal gespannt.
Also noch sehe ich aktuell die Vorteile nicht. Ich habe ein paar Siebeweff-Geräte.
Ich habe ein paar Zigbee-Geräte. Die tun auch alle noch ganz gut.
Also ich sehe jetzt aktuell nicht so, warum ich das unbedingt ändern müsste.
...dass du auf sie urinierst. Es geht aber nicht um irgendeinen Fetisch, sondern um einen Sensor,
den du wie einen Duft-Erfrischer in deinem Toilettenbecken hängst und der dann deinen Urin untersucht.
Smart. Smart-Klo.
Und einer Kassette, die du einlegst und die hin und wieder gewechselt werden muss,
die soll etwa 100 Tests ausführen können.
Zum Start kannst du vor allem Informationen über deine Ernährung...
Wie funktioniert das?
Muss ich da drauf pinkeln?
Oder wie kla... Wie funktioniert das?
...zu wenig oder zu viel Gemüse oder Proteine oder was auch immer du dir nimmst erhalten
oder Informationen zu deinem Reproduktionszyklus.
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich eher für den weiblichen Teil der Zuschauer.
Ich hatte erst Bedenken, was den Datenschutz auf einer Gästetoilette zum Beispiel angeht,
aber die Kiste kann erstmal nur den Urin einer Person im Auge behalten.
Das klingt irgendwie falsch.
Wisst ihr, was das Blöde ist? Wahrscheinlich geht das nur über irgendeinen komischen Cloud-Service
und nur mit der offiziellen App.
Würde dieses Ding auch an einen Web-Service was verschicken können, bei mir lokal?
Es wäre zwar komplett useless, aber wäre irgendwo ein cooles Gimmick im Klo.
...sessoren verbaut, um Toilettenwasser von Urin zu unterscheiden.
Die Kiste soll per Sensor erkennen, welcher Mensch gerade drauf pinkelt
und aufgeladen wird das Ganze per USB-C.
Im Lieferumfang sind dankenswerterweise Handschuhe und Reinigungsmittel enthalten.
Für Europa ist das Ganze schon zugelassen und soll im zweiten Quartal hier auf den Markt kommen.
Und mit den Cartridges für Zyklus-Tracking und Ernährungs-Dingsens soll das 500 Euro kosten.
Boah!
What the fuck, Alter!
Okay, nee, für 500 Euro. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, das kostet vielleicht irgendwie 50, 60 Euro.
Aber für 500 Euro? Nee. Nee, wirklich nicht.
Prost, Natursäck.
Großer Nanoleaf-Rundumschlag. Die neuen Sens-Plus-Lichtschalter gibt es einmal in einer verkapelten und in einer Wireless-Vision.
Die funken über Thread und sollen meta-zertifiziert werden.
Das dumme ist halt wieder. Das ist halt nur so ein Ami-Ding.
Bau doch mal bei uns sowas hier in die Wand ein. Wie willst du das überhaupt gescheit machen?
Soll kein neutraler...
Das geht bei den Amis, wo du die Säge nehmen kannst und einfach mal ein Loch in die Wand schneiden.
Soll jede dimmbare und nicht-dimmbare LED steuern können, so wie alle Nanoleaf-Panels logischerweise.
Aber durch die meta-Zertifizierung kannst du damit eben auch alle anderen meta-Geräte steuern.
Und Sens-Plus wird offenbar ein ganzes Ding.
Und dafür gibt es auch eine Nala-Bridge, die gleichzeitig ein Nachtlicht ist.
Aber Nala steht nicht für Nachtlicht, sondern für Nanoleaf Automation Learning Assistant.
Alles klar.
Das heißt, man kann sowohl die Schalter als auch, wenn du diese Bridge benutzt oder Leuchtmittel mit entsprechenden Sensoren verstehen...
Meta ist neu... Ja, genau. Meta ist ein neuer Standard für IoT-Kommunikation. Richtig.
Allerdings nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig für die Übertragung selbst,
sondern das, was quasi übertragen wird, dass die Geräte miteinander kommunizieren können.
Also Meta ist jetzt quasi kein Layer-2-Wi-Fi-Protokoll oder sowas, sondern quasi das, was du darüber überträgst.
Also du kannst theoretisch, du kannst soweit ich weiß, Meta auch über Wi-Fi machen oder Bluetooth oder Zigbee oder so.
Wobei über Zigbee bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, aber über Wi-Fi auf jeden Fall.
Oder über Thread. Thread ist quasi das eigene Wireless-Protokoll von Meta zur Übertragung.
... wo Lichtschalt ist und mit so einer gewissen Lernphase soll es dann wie Gedankenlesen das Licht schon schalten können,
bevor du das Licht eigentlich geschaltet haben möchtest.
Nanoleaf 4 ist ein Lichtschlauch für den Fernseher mit einer Kamera wie beim Govi, den ich letztes Jahr ausprobierte.
50 Lichtzonen bietet der Lichtschlauch und soll bei 100 Dollar losgehen und ebenfalls...
Ehrlich gesagt, so ein Ding habe ich schon seit Jahren dran.
Ich habe allerdings noch ein Dreamscreen. Die gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Ich habe noch so ein Teil bei mir am Fernseher, das geht nicht mit einer Kamera, sondern über HDMI.
Das musst du quasi pass-through machen, also stöpselst HDMI rein und HDMI zum Fernseher raus und das analysiert das HDMI-Signal.
Und das sieht dann... im Prinzip sieht das so aus.
Startet mit der Montage auf...
So sieht das aus im Hintergrund. Was ist die Latenz? Die ist nahezu nicht existent, also das passt immer gut zum Bild.
Leider haben sie das ganze Produkt eingestellt und...
Naja, jetzt gibt es andere.
Aber das ist praktisch. So was in der Richtung ist das hier wahrscheinlich auch, nur dass es nicht über HDMI pass-through geht, sondern anscheinend mit einer Kamera.
Ja von Philips gibt es sowas schon lange.
Pass-Thru geht, sondern anscheinend mit einer Kamera. Ja, von Philips gibt's sowas schon lange.
...steuerbar sein, wobei dann sicherlich mit reduziertem Funktionsumfang, weil Meta bisher
kein Konzept von 50 Lichtzonen hat und schon gar nicht von Licht, das auf dem Fernseher reagiert.
Und natürlich kannst du damit dann auch deine Nanoli-Fan-Kacheln synchronisieren. Das Ganze
startet im zweiten Quartal, wird in zwei Längen auf den Markt kommen für Fernseher zwischen 55
und 85 Zoll. Alle neuen Meta-Geräte findest du übrigens auch jetzt schon in meiner Meta-Liste
auf spielundzeug.com slash meta. Wie oft kann ich eigentlich Meta sagen, bevor es mich im Schnitt
so sehr langweilt, dass die ganzen Nanoli-Wandpaneele, Linien und was weiß ich wie viel Ecke sollen jetzt
doch alle per Software-Update Meta-Unterstützung bekommen. Und dann kommt noch ein modulares
Deckenlicht, das als zwei oder vier Quadratmeter... Es ist ja auch überhaupt kein Problem, Meta als
Software-Update nachzuliefern, wenn es Wi-Fi-Meta ist. Weil Geräte, die eh schon Wi-Fi haben,
kannst du ohne Probleme upgraden auf Wi-Fi-Meta. Im Starterpaket kommt, die bis zu 3000 Lumen an
Licht liefern sollen, dynamische Licht... Ja, wenn du das über irgendeinen Smart-Home-Hub machst,
dann ist es egal. Dann würdest du ja auch nicht direkt, sagen wir mal, mit dem Schalter jetzt die
Lampe ansteuern, sondern du würdest quasi das in dein Smart-Home-Hub einbinden. Der erkennt,
dass der Schalter gedrückt wurde und steuert dann darauf irgendwie 3-4 Lichter an. Ich glaube,
da geht es eher darum, wenn du es direkt miteinander kommunizieren lässt. Volle 16 Millionen Farben
abbildend. Das Ganze funktioniert per Wi-Fi, soll aber trotzdem Meta-Zertifiziert werden und kommt
im dritten Quartal auf den Markt. Die Nanolief-Dinger sind ja von der Idee her immer ganz, ganz nice,
aber die sind viel, viel zu teuer, finde ich. Also du bezahlst ja für so ein paar Nanolief-Dinger,
für so ein paar diese Nanolief-Dinger, was du halt an die Wand machen kannst,
so diese Kacheln, bezahlst du ja irgendwie für ein paar Stück 180 Euro und sowas. Guck mal,
das ist viel zu teuer, das ganze Zeug. Deswegen habe ich auch noch nie irgendwas in der Richtung
gekauft. Muss ich das mal angucken? Guck mal hier, das kostet einfach hier 250 Euro für...
Wie viele sind das? Wie viele Kacheln sind da drin? 15 Stück, das ist wahnsinnig teuer.
Zumal ich sagen muss, die meiste RGB-Beleuchtung braucht eh kein RGB. Das, was die meisten Leute
wollen an Beleuchtung, ist nicht RGB. Die meisten Leute wollen an- und ausschaltbar, dimmbar und
vielleicht noch den Farbton, also nicht den Farbton, den die Wärme anpassen. Also ob das
rötlicher oder weißer ist, das war es dann aber auch. Also RGB brauchst du bei der meisten
Beleuchtung gar nicht. Und die Nanolief-Dinger sind einfach teuer und dort, wo ich RGB haben will,
dann weiß ich nicht, ob ich es mit Nanolief machen würde. Aber diese Deckenleuchten sollen
die Infrarotsensoren verbaut haben, damit sie die Sense Plus, Nala, was auch immer Geschichte machen
können und lernen, wie du dich bewegst. Und die Platzierung oben in der Mitte... Also wenn mein
Licht lernt, wie ich mich bewege, weiß ich nicht, das spricht mich persönlich nicht so an. Ich will
das wichtigste für mich ist, dass ich das in meinen Smart Home integrieren lässt und zwar lokal. Ohne
Cloud und auch ohne irgendwelche komischen Hacks und Bridges und irgendwelche Custom-Firmwares,
die ich flashen muss. Ich meine, es ist gut, dass es Custom-Firmwares gibt für einige größere
Geräte, verbreitetere Geräte, wo man die dann doch einbinden kann, die standardmäßig Cloud-only sind,
zum Beispiel die für Device-Kameras gibt es, Custom-Firmware oder ganz viele Steckdosen mit
Tasmota-Flaschen, leider immer weniger. Das ist gut, dass es das gibt, aber für mich persönlich
ist natürlich entscheidend, wenn ich mir so was Neues kaufe und die Auswahl habe zwischen ich kann
mir was kaufen, was eben schon von Haus aus ordentlich ansprechbar ist lokal oder Cloud-only,
dann kaufe ich mir immer das, was lokal ansprechbar ist. Das andere würde ich mir auch kaufen, wenn man
es mit ein paar relativ einfachen Tricks umrüsten kann und halt einfach besser ist. Deswegen habe
ich mir beispielsweise auch die Ladestation oder das Ladegerät fürs Auto, die Wallbox fürs Auto,
extra eine gekauft, die eben MQTT und eine Web-API unterstützt. Du kannst das über die App machen,
du kannst das glaube ich auch bei denen über die Cloud machen, aber du kannst das auch ganz normal
lokal über WLAN steuern, über Web-Request und MQTT. Das war mir wichtig, der Grund warum ich mir die
Wallbox gekauft habe, die ich mir gekauft habe, weil die eben kein Cloud-Scheiß- und App-only
Bedienung hat. Und Samsung unterstützen Amazons Echoes bisher Matter ja nur über Wi-Fi und nicht
über Thread. Sie haben jetzt aber noch mal bekräftigt, dass sich das in diesem Frühjahr
ändern soll und dass dann auch die kompatiblen Ero-Router und weitere Geräte entsprechende
Updates bekommen werden. Außerdem wollen sie dann in dem Zuge auch weitere Matter-Gerätetypen
unterstützen, prominenterweise unterstützen, die bisher ja keine Bridges. Außerdem will Amazon
Namen von Räumen und Gruppen... Welche Wallbox hast du? Ich habe ein... das Teil. Und der
ausschlaggebendste Grund warum ich mir das Ding gekauft habe ist, weil die, wenn du die ins WLAN
hängst, direkt über HTTP und MQTT gesteuert werden können und Informationen darüber abfragbar
sind bzw. die selbst über MQTT Informationen publishen. Also ich weiß genau jetzt wie lang
war der letzte Ladevorgang, wie viel Strom wurde gebraucht, wie viel Leistung zieht das gerade,
wie viel Ampere gehen da drüber. Ich kann sagen eine Phase, drei phasig. Also ich kann da auch
vieles drüber einstellen über MQTT, aber vor allem kriege ich halt Infos raus, wie viel Strom
ich verbrauche das zum Beispiel ganz praktisch. Da weiß ich, letzter Ladevorgang hat siebeneinhalb
Stunden gedauert. Und ich habe es jetzt so gemacht, wenn der Lade-Status von Loading auf Inactive
switcht für länger als zwei Minuten, dann kriege ich eine Push-Notification auf mein Handy, dass
das Auto fertig geladen ist, dann kann ich den Stecker abmachen. Das geht theoretisch auch über
die offizielle Fiat App bzw. Fiat kann dir sogar Mails schicken, aber warum? Warum sollte ich das
über irgendeine App machen, wenn ich sie über mein Smart Home regeln kann? Und dann ist natürlich
praktisch, dass die eben offene Schnittstellen hat. Da gucke ich immer drauf, bevor ich mir was
Neues kaufe. Kann ich auch jedem nur empfehlen, weil du kannst dich auf Cloud-Scheiß einfach
nicht verlassen, gerade nicht was Smart Home angeht. Die sehen immer so unglücklich aus,
wie die Ami-Steckdose. Guckt euch das mal an. Richtig tra... Fields Batman. Sättge. Richtige Sättge-Steckdose.
... und auch als Nicht-iPhone-Nutzer Verwendung für die Eve-Geräte hast. Außerdem gibt es die
Eve-Motion-Blinds, die ihre Meta-Zertifizierung ja auch bereits erhalten haben, jetzt neuerdings auch
als Nachrüstmotor für dumme Rollos und was auch immer du damit motorisieren möchtest, was du
vielleicht schon hast. Dann hat Switchboard einen neuen Hub angekündigt, den Hub 2. Der Hub hat jetzt
auch einen Temperatur- und Luftfeuchtesensor eingebaut, sowie ein kleines Display, um diese
Daten direkt ablesen zu können. Die Daten werden allerdings auch an HomeKit durchgereicht und lassen
sich so für allgemeine Automation nutzen. Das ist aber völlig langweilig. Das viel Spannendere ist,
dass der Hub 2 meta-kompatibel sein soll, wenn er dann im Februar erscheint. Aber wozu brauche ich
ein Smart-Bot-Hub? Da kannst du dann bestehendes Switchboard-Geräte anmelden und nach und nach
sollen die per Firmware-Update... Weil die gehen auch ganz normal über WLAN. Wozu brauche ich
dann überhaupt ein Hub? Zum Start geht es erstmal für den Switchboard-Kurten-Gardinen-Motor. Die
Switchboard-Produkte, vor allem der Knopfdrücker, erfreuen sich bei euch ja großer Beliebtheit. Das
Ding ist cool. Wenn sonst nichts geht, Switchboard dran. Und auch das Smart-Bot soll noch in diesem
Jahr ein entsprechendes Update bekommen. Roborock betreibt etwas Modellpflege und hat die S8-Generation
angekündigt. Die gibt es wie gewohnt als S8, als S8 Plus mit Absaugstation, als S8 Ultra mit der
Absaugreinigungs- und Auftankstation. Ein Max-V-Modell gibt es diesmal allerdings nicht mehr. Dafür haben
alle drei Versionen das reactive 3D-getaufte... Die Bedarmung bei Xiaomi blicke ich eh nicht
durch....System, womit der noch besser navigieren soll als die Max-V-Variante des Vorgängers. Und
die haben ebenfalls Kameras und Laser-Navigation kombiniert. Ansonsten wird der Mob ein bisschen
doller gerüttelt. Es gibt doppelte Bodenwalzen und eine nochmals erhöhte Saugleistung. Allerdings
wird die Absaugstation des S8 Plus jetzt wieder zwingend... Also ich verwende meinen Staubsauger-Roboter
aktuell gar nicht mehr. Ich habe aber auch keinen mit automatischer Entleere-Station. Das wäre
tatsächlich das Upgrade, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, wenn ich mir so einhole, dass ich ihn
auch verwenden würde. Weil das Ausleeren ging mir echt auf den Keks. Da flitze ich lieber mit dem
Staubsauger ab und zu mal durch. Das Dumme ist, das ist halt alles mittlerweile mit Kameras
ausgerüstet und Cloud-Only. Meinen S5 konnte ich noch flashen mit Custom-Firmware, aber die
neuen gehen ja gar nicht mehr. Ach das ist... Ein Saugbeutel erfordert. Ist blöd. Das Ultra-Dock
hat jetzt die Trocknung des Mobs integriert und muss nicht mehr mit einem Nachrüst-Fön nachgerüstet
werden. Überwiegend Modellpflege, aber gerade die verbesserte Reinigungsleistung und die doppel
Walzen interessieren mich doch irgendwie. EcoFlow, die in den letzten Monaten eher durch riesige
Power-Station-Akkus auf sich aufmerksam gemacht haben, bringen jetzt... Ist das eine Rasenmäher?
Die mobile Klimaanlage, die sie auf der IFA gezeigt haben, den mobilen... Ist das eine Rasenmäher oder was soll das sein?
Kühlschrank oder die Kühlbox, wie auch immer und auch die Möglichkeit von einigen der großen
Akkus Strom in dein Haus einzuspeisen. Mit den Solar-Panels ist dann quasi ein Inkopeltis bei
Konkraftwerk. Noch spannender finde ich aber dieses... Ja, aber die unterstützen keinen neuen Roborocks
mehr, oder? Nee.
Ah, okay. Ach, man kann die neuen tatsächlich... Man kann die neuen tatsächlich auch wieder
flaschen, die neueren. Oh, das ist cool.
Die FAL-Rooting-Method. Was ist die FAL-Rooting-Method?
Was ist FAL? Hell-Image is 7.
Wir gucken mal kurz, welche Staubsauger-Roboter unterstützt werden, hier Custom-Firmware-Technisch.
Roborock, S7. Tatsächlich, die neuen werden auch unterstützt, inklusive Absaugstation.
Rooting-Instructions FAL. FAL-Rooting is the current recommended method for... Okay.
It's booting a live Linux image that patches the...
Was? TPR 17, also irgendein Pin-to-Low?
Fully Disassembly, including destruction of all warranty seals is... Oh nee, da habe
ich keinen Bock drauf, dass ich meinen Staubsauger-Roboter auseinanderbauen muss, dass ich ihn routen
kann. Oh nee, nee, da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock
drauf. Ja, mit dem F5 war das wirklich einfach. Das
Flaschen. Was ein Riesenakt, einfach nur, dass man den Graben lokal betreiben kann.
Ist doch lächerlich, alles mittlerweile.
Ist doch ein Meh-Roboter. Find ich nice. Mal gucken, wie der die
Grundstücksbegrenzung ordentlich erkennt. Ja, und da musst du es dann...
Ich bin auf jeden Fall sehr interessiert, den durch den Urwald unseres neuen Hauses
fahren zu lassen. Ich auch. Ha, das probiere ich auch aus.
Denkst du, dass man beim Mainstrip schafft, dass man von alles in Cloud wegkommt? Nö.
Brauche ich alles nicht. Brauche ich nicht, weil meine Türklingel verwendet
die Tür-Gegensprechanlage, die schon eingebaut ist, im Haus und ich habe einfach eine Kamera.
Brauche ich nicht, smarte IQ-Klingel. Wenn ihr es an einer meta-kompatiblen Akara
Bridge-Hub-Geschichte anmeldet und dann soll sie, wenn du sie an diesem Hub betreibst,
auch je nach Fingerabdruck, den du zum Beispiel scannst, eine andere Automation ausgelöst
werden können, wie neulich auch in einem der Zuschauer-Automations-Videos. Die zweite Generation
des Präsenzmeldes soll auch im zweiten Quartal in die USA kommen und dann sehen wir den bestimmt
auch bald hier. Meine Hoffnung steigt auf jeden Fall und dann finden wir raus, was auch immer
60 Dollar dann hier umgerechnet sein werden. Und dann kommt noch ein ZigBee-Lichtschlauch
der T1. Da ist er halt einfach so.
Und das
wahrscheinlich nur über die Cloud von denen.
Also
vorerst funktioniert das Ganze in seinem eigenen Schneider-Universum. TP-Link bohrt
sein Tapu-Produktangebot auf und alles soll den Metastandard Embracing. Es gibt ein neues
Türschloss mit
Ja, Marketing, blablabla. Also Türschlösser. Ihr wisst, ich hab sehr viel hier, was SmartHome
angeht, gebastelt. Aber Schlösser ist eine Sache, die schockt mich so gar nicht. Also
SmartLogs hab ich nirgendswo und hab ich bis jetzt auch nicht vor.
Eingebauter Kamera für die USA, aber auch eine Türklingel mit zweiter Kamera für
Pakete auf der Fußmatte oder euren Schuhfingern.
Was ist das? Cockcam oder was?
Es gibt neue Saugroboter, Kameras für drinnen und draußen und das alles ist ein bisschen
merkwürdig, weil der aktuelle Metastandard weder Kameras noch Saugroboter unterstützt.
Also warten wir mal ab, was Embracing-Meta für die Praxis gehört.
Ja, Meta bedeutet wahrscheinlich einfach nur, du kriegst über Meta mit, wenn einer auf
die Türklingel draufklickt mit Kamera und so hat das wahrscheinlich gar nichts zu tun.
Yeelight hat nochmal gesagt, dass sie jetzt drei Produktlinien für Beleuchtung haben.
Yeelight Home für die Beleuchtung zu Hause. Yeelight Fun für Unterhaltungsbeleuchtung
zu Hause.
Nicht zu Hause?
Und Yeelight Pro, ebenfalls für zu Hause, aber irgendwie besser. Meta soll überall
nach und nach Einzug halten, als erstes in die Pro-Geräte per Softwareupdate. Aber bevor
es damit losgeht, kommt sogar dieser Würfel, die Cube Smartlamp. Das Meta-Zertifikat haben
sie dafür wohl schon in der Tasche. Die Lampe enthält drei Arten von Würfeln, Spot, Matrix
und Panel. Die kannst du beliebig zusammensetzen, das wird Teil der Fun-Linie. Ich hoffe, du
hast Spaß am Basteln deiner eigenen Lampe.
Govee hat für ein Update des bereits im Handel befindlichen M1 LED Lightstrip die Meta-Zertifizierung
erhalten. Es gibt noch keinen Termin, wenn das Update kommt, aber es kann jetzt eigentlich
nicht mehr lange dauern.
Siehste, deswegen kann man mit einem ordentlichen Smart Home Zentrale, also wenn man Homocystein
oder sowas verwendet, kann man da so ein bisschen drauf scheißen. Redet der von Facebook
Meta? Nein, der redet von Meta. Das ist ein Smart Home Protokoll. Wenn man aber eine ordentliche
Smart Home Zentrale hat, dann kannst du zum Beispiel einen ZigBee-Lichtschalter nehmen,
einen LED Strip mit WLED als Controller über Wi-Fi und du drückst den ZigBee-Schalter
und die LED geht an und aus, weil der Schalter über ZigBee schaltet, deine Smart Home Zentrale
bekommt es mit und der schaltet dann über WLED den Lightstrip am Fenster ein und aus.
Das ist kein Ding. Deswegen so dieses alles muss alles unterstützen, ist nur für Leute
interessant, die zu blöd dafür sind, das über eine ordentliche Zentrale zu machen.
AI ist auch nur noch ein Buzzword oder? AI wird bei allen mittlerweile draufgeklatscht.
Wobei wir sagen mussten, gerade mal unabhängig von Buzzword, also AI hat schon unglaubliche
Fortschritte gemacht die letzten Jahre. Ich meine sowas wie Smart GPT oder auch GitHub
CodePilot oder dieses Ding, was aus Musik einzelne Instrumente extrahieren kann und
sowas ist schon wirklich nice. War gerade ein Follow-Bot? Weiß ich nicht, ich hab jetzt
nicht geguckt. Keine Ahnung. Nicht schon wieder, oder? Ich hab ja keinen Sound mehr für die
Follows an. Keine Ahnung. Ich hatte schon mal ein Follow-Bot, ja, weiß auch nicht was
da gerade abgeht. Aber hey, ich freu mich, wenn's echte Leute sind.
AI Gaming Syncbox, eine Kiste angekündigt, durch die du dein Fernseh- oder Computerbild
schleifen kannst und dann mit Go-Video... Nee, da geht wirklich, das ist ein bisschen
viele Follows. Guck mal, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf. Das hört ja gar nicht mehr
auf. Okay, irgendeiner von den Leuten, die hier gerade followt, Wolfboy. Moin, schreibt
mal was in den Chat. Oder auch JackCMS. Oder Brockop, was auch immer. Das ist wahrscheinlich
wirklich irgendein Bot, oder? Auch nicht schon wieder, man. Hast du schon Hunger bekommen?
Ja, ich hab schon Hunger. Ich könnte schon jetzt was futtern, ja. Okay, ich werde mal
kurz die Follow-Notifications hier ausschalten, weil das ist doch ein bisschen zu viel, das
Guten. Na gut, dann wird das Ganze sich wahrscheinlich wieder erledigt haben. Das verschwindet dann
wieder in 1-2 Wochen. Twitch filtert sowas ja immer raus. Gucken wir mal weiter. Hast
du schon Chat-GPT ausprobiert? Ja, hab ich. Hab ich tatsächlich. Ich hab schon... Dankeschön
für den Raid, 168 Leute. Poggers. Huge Raid. Ja, ich hab Chat-GPT schon ausprobiert. Wir
haben sogar schon im Stream zusammen ausprobiert. Was hatten wir Chat-GPT gefragt? Achja, wir
haben Chat-GPT gefragt, ob... Genau, wir haben Chat-GPT gefragt, ob Chat-GPT weiß, was man
gegen Backseating macht. Wenn der Twitch-Chat zu sehr Backseated, da hat... Ich weiß nicht
mehr, was Chat-GPT darauf geantwortet hat, aber es war relativ sinnvoll, ja. Vielleicht
waren die Follower doch kein Fake. Man weiß ja nie. Dann pläne ich es wieder ein. Dankeschön
für den Raid. Gut, ehrlich gesagt, ich wollte gerade sagen Host, aber Host gibt es ja nicht
mehr, oder? Glaub nicht, gibt es nicht mehr. Wie häufig geradet. Chainlaw, was hast du
wieder gemacht hier? Eieiei, mit irgendwelchen komischen Ascii-Sachen gespammt. Nee, ist
doch... Ist doch... Ist doch irgendwas am Start. Frauen-Saunaus. Ey, was auf Twitter immer
trendet. Ich guck mir die deutschen Twitter-Trends gar nicht mehr an. Nicht, dass das jetzt
irgendwie verwerflich wäre. Es sind ja Leute mittlerweile schon bei jedem Furz getriggert.
Aber ich kann mir die Posts, die Tweets dort nicht durchliegen. Die sind meistens so unglaublich
bescheuert auf Twitter, alle. Letztendlich geht es auf Twitter bloß darum, der restlichen
Welt zu zeigen, dass man selbst eben der bessere Mensch ist. Das ist der einzige Sinn für
viele auf Twitter. Die sind auf Twitter, um zu zeigen, ich bin besser als ihr. Dezent,
paar Tabs offen. Sei mal froh, dass du jetzt kommst, sondern nicht vor ein paar Monaten,
wo ich mein Desktop noch nicht aufgeräumt hatte. Mittlerweile, zwischenzeitlich, war
mein Desktop sogar so vollgesaut mit Icons, dass das Startmenü geleckt hat beim Aufmachen.
Oh Mist, Leute. Jetzt, weil du gerade sagst, Windows, Mist, hab ich überhaupt meine VMP
in den Stream schon umgezogen. Nee. Chat, wir könnten gar keinen Bastel-Stream und sonst
was machen. Doch, doch, ich hab die VMP, ich kann die rüber kopieren. Ich hab meine
Ledungskiste noch gar nicht umgezogen für den Stream. Die Qt-VMP, die wird nicht umgezogen.
Die bleibt weg. Okay, gucken wir das Video mal, fertig. Hast du einen neuen Rechner mit
frischer Windows-Installation? Korrekt. So sieht's aus. Hands-Champ.
Also, mittlerweile, seit jetzt AI mit Google, mit GitHub-Code-Pilen und Chat-GPT und so
abgegangen ist, jeder pflastert an seinem Produkt einfach AI. Unter der Haube wird das
mit AI wahrscheinlich gar nichts zu tun haben, sondern es ist, also ich gehe nicht davon
aus, dass es wirklich irgendwas hat, was trainiert mit deinen Daten oder vielleicht sogar schon
mit irgendeinem vortrainierten Model kommt oder sowas. Ich gehe davon aus, dass es ganz
simple if-Statements in der Firmware sind und auch nicht sonderlich komplex. Das wird
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nichts mit AI zu tun haben an der Stelle. Der größte AI-Fail,
der mir so einfällt, kennt noch jemand, den Nazi-Bot von Microsoft, den Bing, oder ja,
Microsoft war das. Diesen Twitter-Bot, der irgendwelche Nazi-Sprüche von sich gegeben
hat nach irgendwie zwei Wochen Training, ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Das ging richtig
in die Hose. Oder nur ein paar Stunden, ja, das war wirklich kurz. War das nicht das Ding,
wo es sich damals bei 4chan zusammengetan haben, um diesen Bot mit sinnlosen Messages
zu trainieren? Thai, ja, genau. Microsoft-Thai. Ich kann mich, ich erinnere mich. Aber jetzt
mal gucken, was hier die AI-Gaming-Syncbox macht. Ich werde es nicht ausprobieren.
Oh, jetzt müssen wir wohl ein bisschen Gas geben, sonst sitzen wir hier noch zur nächsten
DS. Ring hat Kameras für Türspione und fürs Auto vorgestellt, die allerdings erst mal nur
in den USA... Wenn dieser Kram ordentlich offline funktionieren würde und nicht nur
über ihre komische Cloud, weil muss ich das mal vorstellen. Eine Kamera, die bei mir im
Haus hängt, streamt die Sachen erst mal, damit ich sie mir angucken kann, über meinen WLAN
ins Internet zu irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter, damit ich sie mir dann dort angucke. Das ist
total unsinnig. Okay, im Auto mag das ja noch sinnvoll sein, aber daheim nicht.
Auf den Mark kommen. Darum ignorieren wir das mal. Reolink. Reolink.
Ja, Shida Kinest Kameras. Von denen habe ich auch ein paar Kameras. Nicht, weil sie qualitativ
so super krass sind, sondern weil sie offline-fähig sind. So ganz klassisch. RTSP-Stream, ich
glaube sogar HLS mittlerweile. Kannst du ganz normal einen Stream drüber laufen lassen,
lokal im WLAN und die haben auch so ziemlich alles, was man braucht. Manche haben ein paar
Stabilitätsprobleme, aber prinzipiell funktionieren die ganz gut. Reolink hat ein paar neue Kameras
gezeigt. Zwei in der Argos-Serie, die mit Batterien betrieben werden. Die Argos-Track
hat zwei Linsen zum automatischen Tracken und Zoom, 2K-Auflösung, Dualband-Wi-Fi und
eingebaute LED-Spotlights, um auch nachts farbige Aufnahmen aufnehmen zu können. Die
Argos-PT4K ist beweglich und hat einen 4K-Sensor. Diese Kameras finde ich persönlich extrem
interessant. Wisst ihr, was das ist? Das ist eine Kamera, die kein 180 Grad aufnehmen.
Das sind quasi zwei Kameras, die machen dann aber ein Bild daraus. Du hast dann quasi
eine ultraweit-Winkel-Aufnahme, ohne dass es ein weit-Winkel ist. Also ohne, dass du
irgendwie das Bild verzerrt hast. Das heißt einfach eine Kamera, die nimmt dort 90 Grad
auf und eine, die dort 90 Grad aufnimmt und das fügt das zusammen und dann hast du quasi
so ein 180 Grad Bild, kannst du quasi deine komplette Hausfront irgendwie oder einen kompletten
Hof an einer Seite filmen, ohne dass das Bild kacke aussieht. Das ist eine ziemlich
coole Sache.
Hier hat es Wi-Fi-Verbindungen und dann gibt es noch eine Kamera, die das beides vereint.
Zwei Linsen und 4K. Die braucht aber per PoE Stromversorgung, weil sie das sonst nicht
mit dem Akku abbilden könnte. GE hat seiner smarten Beleuchtungs-Serie jetzt den neuen
Namen Sync verpasst und war das Ganze im gleichen Atemzug deutlich aus. Neue Leuchtmittel, mehr
Effektbeleuchtung. Allerdings ist hier erstmal fragwürdig, ob das...
Das brauche ich. Das will ich haben. Poggers, endlich mal ordentliche RGB-Beleuchtung.
...zu uns nach Europa schwappt. Mehr Konkurrenz zu Philips Hue wäre sicherlich willkommen,
bis wir Näheres wissen, lege ich auch das erstmal auf Eis. L'Oreal hat zwei Produkte
angekündigt, für die ich jetzt nicht unbedingt die Zielgruppe bin. Einmal den Bro-Magic.
Also nicht den Bro-Magic, sondern den Bro-Magic.
Ach so.
Ein Kleingedreh, das dir die perfekten Augenbrauen für genau dein Gesicht in die Fresse stempelt.
Was?
Also ein bisschen wie diese Paket-Drucke, ziehst du das einmal durch das Gesicht und
der spuckt dir dann Augenbrauen-Optik übers Auge.
Was? Hab ich das jetzt richtig verstanden? Das ist quasi ein smarter Augenbrauen...
Okay, ich bin verwirrt. Was macht das Ding eigentlich genau?
Färbt das deine schon bestehenden Augenbrauen oder musst du dir vorher deine Augenbrauen
abrasieren und dann machst du dir damit neue drüber?
Ich check... was ist das genau?
Frauen haben oft keine Augenbrauen. Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie eine Frau gesehen, die keine
Augenbrauen hat. So normal kann das nicht sein. Oder du meinst es gibt welche, die schneiden
sich das irgendwie ab. Die schneiden sich das ab.
But why? Und dann malt man sich sowas oben drüber oder wie?
Okay, das ist... muss ich nicht verstehen.
What? Okay, das kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen,
dass das was halbwegs sinnvoll ist. Was weiß ich... Leute die Parkinson haben oder sowas
und sich mit dem Lippenstift die Lippe schön... Okay, das mag ja durchaus sein Anwendungsgebiet
haben.
Quasi ein Gimbal für Lippenstifte. Hätte ich jetzt auch nicht sofort erwartet, ergibt
aber irgendwie auch ein bisschen Sinn, glaube ich.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Sind die Sachen für die jeweilige Zielgruppe eine gute Idee?
Du kannst beim Autofahren schminken. Das ist eigentlich auch cool. Du kannst beim Autofahren
schminken. Das ist wackelt dann. Da guckst du halt nicht auf die Straße. Ich meine, ist
ja egal. Guckst halt lieber dahin und dann machst du mit der...
...weiblichen Zuschauer oder vielmehr die Make-upfahrenden Zuschauer gerne in den Kommentaren aufklären.
Die beheizten Ember-Thermoskanne gibt es jetzt auch mit eingebauter FindMy-Funktion, damit
du deine 200 Euro Thermoskanne nicht von unten noch mit dem AirTag bekleben musst, damit
das ganze Ding am Ende kippelt.
Was ist eine smarte Thermoskanne? Was kann die? Was ist an der...
Dafür ist der jetzt eingebaut. Von Ikea kommt jetzt neu der Windstürke.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken. Ember... Was für eine... Ember...
Travel Mach 2.
Okay. Was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder?
Darf ich jetzt auf der Seite bleiben? Ist das okay? Ja, nice.
Also, der Ember Travel Mach 2 redefines your hot drinking experience und darunter geht's
schon mal gar nicht. Ich mein, für 200 Dollar muss es auch meine
Drinking Experience redefine, sonst ist das wahrscheinlich nicht wert.
Okay, das redefine nicht nur meine Drinking Experience, sondern das rettet auch Leben,
Leute. Help save lives.
Ach so, weil sie irgendwelche Sachen spenden davon.
Ich dachte, die Thermoskanne rettet Leben.
Smart heated Travel Mach... Okay, smart heated.
Okay, was macht das smart da drin? Also, man stellt eine Temperatur ein und
da ist dann wahrscheinlich... Also, ich vermute mal, es ist ein Akku drin.
Man stellt eine Temperatur ein und der versucht, die Temperatur zu halten.
Das geht natürlich nur, wenn du was Heißes reinfüllst und es trotzdem gut isoliert hast,
weil mit einem Akku was Heizen vergisst es. Also, kannst du machen, aber nicht oft und
schon mal gar nicht lang. Mit einem Akku, was warm halten, was gut
isoliert ist, brauchst du nicht so viel Energie. Das kann durchaus funktionieren.
Drei Stunden hält das? Na, Wahnsinn. Für drei Stunden brauche ich natürlich
unbedingt... All day when placed on charging.
Ja, logisch, wenn ich... Okay, also im Endeffekt, ich könnte mir damit
morgens Tee reinfüllen, auf die Arbeitsstelle und einfach einen USB-Kabel anschließen und
dann bleibt mein Tee den Tag über warm. Ich könnte allerdings auch einfach, wenn ich
Tee trinken will, in die Küche gehen und was holen, anstatt den ganzen Tag neben mir
stehen zu lassen. Das ist auch wieder sowas, warum muss es
Touch sein, warum kann es kein Button sein. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, so von der Haptik
und dem Feeling her, wäre es wahrscheinlich viel angenehmer, man würde auf ein Knopf
Minus drücken und auf ein Knopf Plus anstatt Touch, aber Touch ist natürlich sehr nice,
weil Touch immer besser, weil Knöpfe sind out. Temperature range 50 bis 62 Grad.
Weiß nicht, wie warm mein Tee normalerweise ist, keine Ahnung, aber klingt jetzt erstmal
irgendwie ganz sinnig. Intelligisense, ja gut, das hat einen Temperatursensor
drin und das merkt, wenn es fällt, dann wird es warm und wenn es zu warm, dann wird es...
Ach, das ist gar keine Thermoskanne, man trinkt auch direkt da draus.
Ach, das ist doch nicht mal zu oben, das ist offen oder was?
Okay, dann verstehe ich den Sinn davon gar nicht.
Okay, doch, man kann es doch zumachen, weil so könnte ich wenigstens meinen Tee reinfüllen
und dann mit auf die Arbeit nehmen, wenn man dort kein Tee machen kann.
Wie viel passt denn da eigentlich rein, da passt doch wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal so
viel rein. Wie viel passt denn da rein?
355 Milliliter, das ist jetzt aber nicht so viel.
Ich meine, ein halber Liter, was da reinpasst, das ist quasi ein Drittel, fast so 333, also
so ein Drittel Liter, das ist so... Da kommst du echt nicht so, sondern nicht weit, weil
du ganz davon abgesehen, so 350 Milliliter hast du noch ausgedruckt, bevor es kalt ist.
Naja, nee, das ist für dich irgendwie reichlich unsinnig.
Lass mal kurz gucken, was hat denn das? Was hat denn das für Bewertungen auf Amazon?
Auf jeden Fall schon mal ordentlich teuer. Das ist der Cup, den anderen gibt es hier
gar nicht. Naja, naja, das ist wirklich irgendein Gimmick,
wo ich die Daseinsberechtigung noch kritisch sehe.
Hey, das ist ein neuer. Das ist der, den wir hier im Stream auch
mal umgebaut haben. Moment, wie hieß das Ding, was wir hier im Stream umgebaut haben? Moment,
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, das hieß doch auch so ähnlich. IKEA. Hier, Windrick...
Okay, okay, also wir haben, wir haben den IKEA Windrick... Sekunde. Windrickning. Windrickning.
Windrickning haben wir umgebaut im Stream zusammen und das sah dann am Ende so aus.
Da ist er, ja. Und am Ende haben wir uns dann zusammengebaut. Ja, genau, am Ende hat man
dann über TAS Motor die Werte davon bekommen. Also ich habe den Luftqualitätssensor davon
benutzt und ich habe noch einen zusätzlichen BME 680 reingelegt in das Gehäuse. Genau,
das haben wir hier im Stream. Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Genau. Ja. Und das
ist jetzt nicht mehr der Windrickning, sondern der Windstirka mit einem Display vorne drauf.
Also es ist quasi auch ein Luftqualitätssensor, nur mit extra Display. Weil meiner hat vorne
ja bloß eine LED, ob okay ist oder nicht. Miss der genau? Ich würde sagen, die Messungen
sind schon durchaus okay. Das Dumme ist nur, korrekt, das ist, das wollte ich nämlich
gerade sagen. Also es gibt zwei Sachen, die darin ziemlich blöde sind. Erstens der Lüfter
ist doof vom aktuellen und die Messungen sind nach ein paar Wochen ziemlich unsinnig. Also
man muss das regelmäßig durchpusten oder theoretisch regelmäßig saugen und sauber
machen, dass das weiterhin gut funktioniert. Das finde ich auch nervig. Wie teuer ist so
ein Ding? Ich glaube dieser 40 Euro oder so. Ne, das kann es nicht sein. Gibt es auch
nicht bei Amazon, sondern bei Ikea. So billig mittlerweile. Hat er nicht immer mehr gekostet.
Aber dafür kann man nicht viel verkehrt machen. Aber es ist wirklich nicht so toll. Das ganze
Lüfter ist nervig und die Genauigkeit ist okay, aber das verstaubt schnell und du musst
sauber machen. Also ich sage euch wie es ist, ich habe das Ding jetzt eine Weile im Einsatz
gehabt, fand ich ganz nice, aber ich habe es mittlerweile abgestöpselt wieder, weil
ich keinen Bock habe, das alle 14 Tage oder so sauber zu machen. Kennst du gute Alternativen?
Ne. Ich hoffe halt, dass der neue nicht so nervigen Lüfter hat. Scheint so ist. Was
ist für Luftqualität? Ikea. Und das hier ist der neue. Was haben die eigentlich immer
für Wohnzimmer? Also jetzt mal im Ernst, wie ungemütlich und uneinladend möchte man
denn sein Wohnzimmer gestalten? Das sieht eher aus wie so eine Empfangshalle von der
Bank mit einem Sofa reingestellt. Gut, das ist wahrscheinlich krasses Designer Wohnzimmer,
ja dann das sieht das halt so aus, aber irgendwie sieht das nicht so aus, als würde mir das
gefallen. Auch mit den mit den Kacheln und dem grauen Boden und so was. Keine Anschlüsse
am Gerät hat, sondern du hast einen kleinen Würfel. Sieht aus wie der Empfang im RZ Kleierstraße.
Ach du kennst das RZ Kleierstraße, das kenne ich auch. Das kenne ich auch, da war ich früher
auch öfters mal. Allerdings muss man in dem Empfang, also als ich da als ich als ich
dahin gefahren bin öfters, musste man in dem Empfang noch rechts rum, am Parkplatz rechts
rum zu den Security Leuten und die haben mir dann Schlüssel gegeben. Das war so eine ganz
kleine, so eine ganz kleine Bude. Es sah nicht aus wie dort.
So dass du keinen zusätzlichen Stick mehr für deinen Fernseher kaufen musst, um deinen
Samsung Fernseher als SmartThings Basis und dann in Zukunft eben auch als Metabasis nutzen
zu können. Okay, will ich gar nicht. Dafür verwende ich
mein Home Assistant und Gutes. Das mache ich doch nicht mit meinem Fernseher, man.
Außerdem gibt es auf... Weiß ich was mit den Herstellern los ist,
aber warum sollte ich mein Fernseher als Smart Home Zentrale verwenden wollen? Wenn überhaupt
ist der Fernseher ein Gerät, was da drinnen hängt. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, mein Fernseher
ist überhaupt nicht großartig eingebunden. Das einzige, was ich machen kann bei meinem
Fernseher ist an und ausschalten und ich sehe in welchem Betriebszustand der ist, weil ich
will, wenn es nach 23 Uhr ist und der Fernseher aus oder nach 22 Uhr habe ich so eingestellt,
wenn es nach 22 Uhr ist und der Fernseher ausgeschaltet wird, dann wird der ins Bett
gehen Modus aktiviert. Das heißt nach 10 Minuten gehen Lichter im Wohnzimmer und im
Flur aus. Und das klappt zu 990 Prozent gut. Das simple Automatisierung klappt aber gut.
Ateno Dankeschön für den Zapp. Ja und umgedreht könnte man es auch machen, dass man den ausschaltet.
Ganz im Ernst, diese ganzen proprietären Geschichten. Jeder Hersteller braucht eine eigene Box,
eine eigene Zentrale, eine eigene Bridge. Das ist komplett für ein Arsch. Dann endet
man irgendwann so wie der Smart Home Solver, von dem haben wir uns ja auch schon einige
Videos angeguckt, der irgendwie 38 Apps auf seinem Smartphone braucht, um sein Haus steuern
zu können. Deswegen kommt Matter. Ich bezweifle, dass Matter da wirklich grundlegend was dran
ändern wird. Zumal das Beste nach wie vor, was man machen kann ist, sich irgendeine ordentliche
Zentrale hinzustellen, weil dann kann man alles darin integrieren, unabhängig davon,
ob es Matter kann und unabhängig davon, ob der Hersteller Bock darauf hat. Ich kann zum
Beispiel ohne Probleme, könnte ich. Ich spinne mir jetzt mal was zusammen. Also ich könnte
zum Beispiel ohne Probleme darauf reagieren, wenn ich das Ladegerät an mein Elektroauto
stöpsele, könnte ich den Fernseher ausschalten zum Beispiel. Es ist zwar unsinnig jetzt
erst mal, aber da sieht man, das hängt damit zusammen und was ja auch sinnvoll ist, weil
stellt euch mal vor, ich fahre los mit dem Auto und ich habe den Fernseher vergessen
auszumachen. Das kannst du nicht ohne ordentliche Zentrale regeln und ich könnte beispielsweise
dann auch niemals meine ganzen LEDs steuern, die mit WLED angesteuert werden. WLED, das
ist Custom Firmware für Microcontroller und daran hängt dann ganz normalen LED-Strip
und das ganze wird über Wi-Fi gesteuert. Nichts Matter, nicht Thread, nicht Zigbee,
ganz normales eigenes Wi-Fi Ding. Die Shelley-Dinger über WLAN kannst du darüber ansteuern und
das alles zu integrieren oder sich nur Matter-Sachen zu kaufen ist ja auch irgendwo nicht praktikabel.
Warum sollte ich das alte Zeug auch alles wegschmeißen? Es gibt auch vieles Zeug, das wird mit Matter-Support
gar nicht geben und auch ordentliche Automatisierungen, Abläufe erstellen, wirst du so mit ein paar
Klicken auf dem Fernseher auch nicht machen können. Also das ist immer noch, was heißt
immer noch, es ist der beste Weg und wird auch der beste Weg bleiben und wird in Zukunft
auch der beste Weg sein, die Sachen selbst zu integrieren über sowas wie Home Assistant
zum Beispiel, es kann auch meinetwegen Open Hub sein oder was gibt es dann sonst noch,
IO Broker oder sowas in der Richtung. Da kannst du einfach viel besser miteinander, guck mal,
du kannst da zum Beispiel, nur ein Beispiel wo dir Matter gar nicht hilft, stell dir mal
vor du hast eine Lampe im Flur, da ist eine RGB Lampe, meinetwegen auch eine RGB Lampe
mit Matter-Support und du möchtest jetzt, dass die Lampe dir im Flur anzeigt, wenn du
aufstehst morgens, ob deine Bahn Verspätung hat oder nicht. Also sagen wir mal, die Lampe
ist halt normal, wenn die Bahn pünktlich ist und rötlich, wenn die Bahn Verspätung
hat oder orange, wenn sie 5 Minuten hat und über 10 Minuten rot oder sowas. Das ist glaube
ich mal gar nicht so weit von der Realität weg, was man da machen würde. Wie bekommst
du jetzt die Informationen von der Bahn in deine Lampe rein? Da bringt dir Matter nichts,
da bringt dir auch sonst was nichts. Du brauchst irgendeine Zentrale, irgendein Smart Home
System, was auf der einen Seite die Informationen von der Bahn API abfragen kann oder du es
zumindest damit füttern kannst und auf der anderen Seite auch deine Lampe ansteuern kann.
Und da bringt dir das ganze Zeug nichts, da brauchst du eine Zentrale und jeder der ernsthaft
Smart Home Technik was macht, der wird auch eine haben, sei es Home Assistant oder sei
es IO Broker, Open Hub oder was auch immer. Ich persönlich mag Home Assistant, ich habe
aber zusätzlich auch einen IO Broker am Start für ein paar Sachen, die sich so nicht so
schön in Home Assistant integrieren lassen. Zum Beispiel gibt es für IO Broker ein richtig
cooles Plugin, um Amazon Sendungen zu tracken und die Sachen empfange ich dann über IO
Broker und leite sie über MQTT an Home Assistant weiter. Ja das artet aus, das artet dann aus,
wenn du mehr als eine Sache integrieren willst miteinander. Also wenn du nur diesen einen
Anwendungsfall hast, dann machst du drei Zeilen Skript und gut ist, sofern du irgendwie die
Möglichkeit hast easy aus deinem Skript überhaupt deine Lampe anzusteuern. Aber wenn du dann sagst
ah ok ich hätte jetzt gerne noch das ab 10 Uhr abends die Beleuchtung ausgeschaltet wird und
dann will ich natürlich auch wenn ich im Bett mein Handy angeschlossen habe, dass ich eine
Message kriege, dass alle Lichter aus sind, dass der Fernseher aus ist, ich will vielleicht ab und
zu mal im Fischteich die Pumpe einschalten und sowas. Da wird es kompliziert und die ganzen
hunderten Services, die willst du ja nicht alle von Hand integrieren und selbst programmieren,
dafür sind halt Smart Home Zentrale und Smart Home Systeme sowas wie Home Assistant einfach
praktisch. Bei mir steht die Lampe auch wirklich oft auf rot. Wenn die Bahn, was du machen könntest
ist, wenn du diesen neuen Smart Klo Einsatz hast, was du machen könntest ist, jedes Mal wenn es neue
Daten empfängt, könntest du ein Pastebin erstellen und dann an den Bahnsupport oder an Bahntwitter
schicken, wenn du das gerne machen willst. In Home Assistant hast du eine grafische Oberfläche,
wo du dir deine Automatisierung zusammenklicken kannst. Es gibt ja auch Templates mit fertigen
Sachen, aber das ist darüber relativ einfach. Viel besser als ihr komisches Jammelzeug,
was wir früher hatten. Und IFTTT kannst du auch vergessen für vieles. IFTTT ist einfach
langsames Fach. IFTTT ist cool für die Handvoll an Services, die man verwenden will, die das
unterstützen und die Reaktionszeit ist bei IFTTT halt total langsam. Was du mit IFTTT
beispielsweise nicht machen könntest ist, du stehst vor dem Hoftor und möchtest es öffnen,
dann hast du halt Pech, weil IFTTT auch mal 10-15 Sekunden brauchen kann, bis es funktioniert.
Das ist alles nix. Also du brauchst eine ordentliche Smart Home Zentrale, sonst funktioniert es nicht,
wenn du das ernsthaft machen willst.
Du zahlst für die App aber trotzdem 130 und wenn du den Fernseher verkaufst,
oder der kaputt geht, hast du eben gar keinen Sünden mehr. Ja, was bescheuertes.
In dem Fall kann aber vielleicht der Samsung Bespoke Offen für deine Unterhaltung sorgen.
Bespoke Offen, der ist quasi nur für mich angefertigt. Die sind aber nett bei Samsung.
Und ein Chip mit einer künstlichen Intelligenz. Alter, mein Gott, die labern einen Scheiß mit KI.
Das hat mit KI wahrscheinlich überhaupt nichts zu tun. Oder ist es jetzt auch schon KI,
wenn meine Webseite erkennt, dass ab 18 Uhr das Darkseam automatisch eingeschaltet wird?
Es ist auch KI, oder? Ich habe eine Webseite, die hat gelernt, dass ab 18 Uhr das Darkseam sinnvoll ist im Winter.
So, das waren die wichtigsten, also die wichtigsten Sachen, von denen ich jetzt weiß.
Wenn sich noch was tut, dann wird es bei Instagram sicher ein Update geben.
Und abonnieren des Kanals nicht vergessen für mehr Technik für zu Hause.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Jetzt wissen wir auch, dass wir demnächst Smart Home technisch
unser Urin analysieren können, ob genug Vitamine drin sind.
Also das Ding würde ich mir tatsächlich kaufen, wenn es nicht 500 Euro kosten würde, Leute.
500, wie ist dieses Ding nochmal? Sekunde, das muss ich jetzt mal kurz nachgucken.
Wie ist das? Withings use scan.
Ah, das da. First, Moment, wir machen mal kurz das Darkseam hier aus.
First Hands Free Connected Urin Lab.
Ah, da ist es, da ist es.
Jetzt muss ich was gucken.
Kann man da custom firmware flashen? Oh ja, das wäre interessant.
Register. Ich meine, ich finde es von der Idee her irgendwie cool.
Aber 500 Euro, man. 500 Euro. Jetzt übertreibt es halt mal nicht.
Ich meine, was wird da groß drin sein? Was?
Es ist ja, das ist ja noch das nächste.
Das ist auch nur reinklaut basiert, höchstwahrscheinlich.
Du kannst doch nicht mal einfach.
Dein, dein ist jetzt so, als ob es mal ordinär zu sagen.
Du kannst noch nicht mal die Analyse deiner eigenen Pisse bei dir lokal an einen Web Server schicken.
Nein, du musst das an irgendeinen fucking Cloud Anbieter schicken,
was du wie viel Vitamin C du in deinem Urin drinne hast.
Und dann kostet es auch noch, da wollen die auch noch 500 Euro für haben.
Ich frage mich, was der was wirklich der Sinn davon ist, dass man das rein über die Cloud machen kann.
Also was die was die uns erzählen wollen.
Und unterm Strich ist natürlich, dass sie unser, dass sie unsere ganzen Daten haben.
Aber was ist der Sinn davon überhaupt?
Ich meine, mal angenommen, ich will zum Arzt gehen und sagen Guck mal in meinem Urin ist ganz, ganz viel das und das drinne.
Dann mache ich halt einen Screenshot.
Meinetwegen, ja, oder habs bei mir gespart. Aber warum muss das unbedingt in der Cloud sein?
Dann wissen die China Chinesen schon, wenn deine Freundin oder eine Frau schwanger ist, bevor du das selbst weißt, stellt euch das mal vor.
Das ist was.
Und wenn das Vitamin und wenn die Vitamin Vitamin C unten drunter ist, kriegst du automatisch eine Packung Brause Tabletten geschickt.
Also der Preis und Cloud Only ist halt macht es wieder für mich uninteressant.
Na gut.
Okay, was haben wir noch? Kann man doch irgendwas angucken?
Ich krieg Leute drei Stunden. Ihr wisst, was jetzt ist. 12 Uhr. Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was jetzt eigentlich ist?
Eigentlich ist Fude Fude.
Dann hat Nudeln.
Ja, Nudeln, Nudeln, Nudeln mit Lachs gibt es heute.
Nudeln mit Lachs übrig geblieben von gestern.
Nudeln mit Lachs und China Chinesen scharfer Soße drüber.
Was Spannendes.
Okay, das ist Chibate oder This Awesome Mini Monitor ist cheap und useful. Zeig mal her. Stimmt Chibated.
Ist es überhaupt nicht useful?
Quasi ein ein Stream Deck mit Bildschirm.
Okay, gibt es gibt es ja mittlerweile auch komplette Gehäuse für den Raspberry Pi, wo du hinten Raspberry Pi dran machst und vorne hast so ein Gehäuse.
Aber ich finde den Formfaktor tatsächlich ganz nützlich, weil das ist nicht so hoch. Das ragt auf jeden Fall nicht in den anderen Bildschirm rein.
Die anderen sind meistens so 16 9 oder sowas. Dann hast du dann hier so ein. Das finde ich vom Formfaktor schon mal ganz ganz praktisch.
Auf der anderen Seite ganz ehrlich, wirklich sinnvoll erscheint es mir nicht, weil ich habe zwei Bildschirme und ich kann einfach auf den zweiten Bildschirm links alles schieben oder alles aufmachen am anderen Rechner auch oder auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Was ich offen haben will und ein Auge drauf haben werfen möchte öfter. Also wirklich sinnvoll. Ich weiß nicht.
Es lässt sich da Doom drauf spielen bestimmt. Ich meine, es lässt sich sogar Doom auf dem Drucker spielen.
Ich hatte nie so eine Logitech mit Tastatur. Ich hatte nie eine Logitech Tastatur mit Display.
Logitech mit Tastatur hatte ich schon. Ich habe keine Logitech mit Tastatur. Die alten hatten ja noch schwarz weiß Displays. Die neuen kenne ich gar nicht.
Computer und kann alles displayen, was du willst.
Weißt du, eines der Lieblingssachen von allen Leuten, die Smart Home Dashboards bauen und solche solche Sachen ist immer die Wetter Anzeige ganz im Ernst.
Wie oft am Tag guckt ihr eigentlich aufs Wetter? Ich gucke da morgens beim Frühstück vielleicht mal zwei Minuten in die Wetter App und den restlichen Tag einfach gar nicht mehr.
Ich brauche nicht den permanenten überall Anzeige Wetter und Wetter Radar und wenn ich das brauche, wenn ich das brauche, jedes Mal wenn ich in Flur gehe, muss ich einfach nur rechts gucken auf mein Dashboard.
Da steht drauf Temperatur, also Uhrzeit, Temperatur und alle Daten von meiner Wetter Station, also sprich ob es regnet, ob es geregnet hat, gefühlte Temperatur, normale Temperatur, Windstärke.
Ich glaube das war es. Regen über die letzte Stunde steht drauf genau und so war es solche Geschichten.
Das reicht mir in der Regel auch, wenn ich wirklich mal was wissen muss.
Aber es ist viel, viel kleiner. Es ist auch ein Touchscreen, das bedeutet, dass ich meine Finger mit Windows oder Programmen verwenden kann.
Also was genau schauen wir hier an?
Die Reason ist Aliexpress.
Für 60 Euro bekommt ihr theoretisch einen zweiten Bildschirm, das ist richtig, einen richtig großen.
Der Anwendungszweck bei ihm ist ja was anderes, er will ja explizit was kleines haben und sein Schreibtisch ist ja schon voll mit seinem großen Bildschirm.
Für so kleine Bildschirme ist das vollkommen in Ordnung.
Es ist kleiner als das Display in meinem Auto, also es ist wirklich nicht sonderlich groß.
Erst mal Grafana drauf.
Ich finde ich persönlich schon wieder nicht sinnvoll, weil dann müsste ich mir einen Shortcutbutton da hin machen und dann müsste ich von der Tastatur weggreifen oder von der Maus weggreifen und da drauf touchen und auch richtig zielen und sowas.
Dann habe ich lieber einen Shortcut auf der Tastatur, wenn es so wichtig ist oder ich sage hier irgendwie blub, gut ja unter Windows funktioniert das nicht aber unter Linux wäre das kein Ding und starte dann schnell was.
Das Gerät kostlos, kann sein, es ist aber nicht gefleckt als Werbung. Aber wer weiß, wer weiß. Er hat schon mal einen guten Hintergrund.
Also ich finde meine Tabs sind extrem organisiert.
Da würde ich auch nichts drauf finden mit dem Farbschimmer.
Leute ich bin immer begeistert, die Schreibtische von vielen Leuten in den Videos die sehen immer so ordentlich und aufgeräumt aus und ihr müsst immer mein Schreibtisch sehen, da liegen Sachen, die sind 5 Jahre alt.
Ich habe letztens wieder einen Brief gefunden, 2013.
Okay.
Das erscheint mir sogar noch irgendwie sinnvoll, dass man sein Kalender im Blick hat. Ich meine, ich gucke einmal morgens drauf und kriege eh 15 Minuten vor irgendwelchen Meetings nochmal eine Notification.
Aber okay, wenn man da gerne tagsüber immer mal wieder drauf guckt, okay, warum nicht?
Okay.
Discord macht ja blimp.
Wobei ich habe alle Discord Töne aus.
Ich habe jetzt nichts erkannt, wo ich sage, oh ja, das würde voll helfen.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute mögen nun block.
Die Maus ist auch super, wie kann der mit der Maus überhaupt was bedienen?
Was hat der für eine Sense auf seiner Maus?
Der hat einen eins bis zwei Zentimeter links und eins bis zwei Zentimeter.
Okay.
Juckt doch kein.
Da ist doch wahrscheinlich irgendein Lack oder so drüber.
Da wird wahrscheinlich erst mal gar nichts passieren.
Okay, also für mich für mich jetzt eigentlich eher überflüssig.
Brauche ich dich jetzt nicht?
Okay, wir scrollen da mal kurz durch, warum?
Weil es ein neuer Lüfter ist.
Es ist leise und es bläst.
Also ich bin echt zufrieden mit meinem neuen Case.
Ich bin immer noch am überlegen oder eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich war ja immer noch am überlegen, ob ich mir noch einen dritten Frontlüfter kaufe dafür.
Aber es passt alles.
Also ich werde es zu lassen.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Frontlüfter, einen Backlüfter, also hinten und oben ist halt die Wasserkühlung drin, die auch Luft raussaugt.
Also ich habe theoretisch ein bisschen mehr, also unter ordentlich Last natürlich, ein bisschen mehr Lüfter, die Sachen aus dem Gehäuse rauspusten als reinpusten, was eigentlich nicht so gut ist,
weil in der Regel willst du ein bisschen Überdruck haben, dass weniger Staub durch die Ritzen reingeht und sowas.
Aber ist okay, also kann mich nicht beschweren.
Also ich habe jetzt schon genug Benchmarks laufen lassen und Prime 95 mal zwei, drei Stunden.
Also das höchste, was ich geschafft habe, ist übrigens an Energieverbrauch.
Was ich an Energieverbrauch geschafft habe, war 750 Watt, so über den Daumen gepeilt, 750 Watt.
Da habe ich Prime 95 laufen lassen auf quasi fast allen Kern, aber ich habe zwei Kerne, ich habe zwei Kerne freigelassen, um dann, ich glaube,
auf Vormark laufen zu lassen, dieser Donut für die GPU und dann war das bei 750 Watt.
Also viel mehr wird nicht gehen.
Hast du auch Leistungsspitzen für kurze Zeit?
Also nicht, dass ich da irgendwas von gemerkt hätte, wenn ich ein YouTube Video starte.
Was ich für ein Case habe, du kannst dir angucken, was ich für ein Rechner habe.
Moment, ich habe irgendwo einen Link.
Ach, da ist er doch.
Hallo Leute.
Ja, da ist er.
Guck hier, da ist ein neuer Rechner.
Das ist ein, ich habe übrigens, ich habe noch ein bisschen umgebaut zu diesem Video.
Also der Adapter ist weg, ich habe mir so einen Be Quiet Adapter gekauft, was eben direkt ans Netzteil geht.
Und dieses Kabel hier, das da, das Kabel geht jetzt hier auch so nicht mal drüber, das kommt jetzt hier oben raus und geht direkt ans Mainboard.
Also das, da müssen die ganzen Leute in den Comments auch nicht mehr getriggert sein.
Also hier kannst du dir angucken, was ich aktuell, du kannst auch Ausrufezeichen PC machen im Chat, genau.
Kannst du dir, kannst du dir hier angucken, was es ist.
Und das Gehäuse ist ein Fractal Design Mashify 2 XL.
Warum XL?
Damit auf jeden Fall die Wasserkühlung reinpasst, weil die Wasserkühlung hat 3 140 Millimeter Lüfter.
Ist also schon ein bisschen größer.
Und die Wasserkühlung braucht auch, wenn man sich das Case, also das Case ist schon relativ groß.
Die Wasserkühlung braucht auch nahezu, das nimmt auch nahezu die komplette, die komplette Größe hier in Anspruch.
Ich gucke da mal kurz drauf oben.
Ja, nicht die komplette.
Also sag mal hier vorne, hier vorne sind noch so 2, 3 Zentimeter frei.
Also ich könnte noch eine größere Wasserkühlung.
Ja.
Ich muss übrigens mal Amazon Ref Links von allem erstellen.
Easy Money, Easy Life.
Ja, also das aktuelle Case, was ich habe.
So Leute, ich weiß, wir haben letzten Tage, letzten 1, 2 Wochen auch ein bisschen wenig Streams gemacht.
Ich hoffe, dass es nächste Woche besser klappt.
Jetzt die erste Woche arbeiten rum.
Wieder mehr Home Office.
Wir müssen nämlich noch ein paar Sachen basteln.
Und wieder Zeit.
Ich glaube, ich habe die letzten, das letzte Stream, den ich gemacht habe, war tatsächlich letzten Sonntag.
Und davor glaube ich auch nur letzten Sonntag.
Also ich habe nicht so viel gestreamt die letzten, die letzten Wochen über.
Gucken, dass es wieder ein bisschen mehr wird.
Aber ihr wisst, wie es ist.
Ich habe manchmal Phasen, da stream ich jeden Tag.
Und manchmal auch nur alle paar Tage oder vielleicht auch nur einmal die Woche.
Kreisegrind, genau.
Okay, Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Was machst du beruflich?
Kannst du dir bei mir auf YouTube angucken?
Da habe ich 3, 4 Videos zugemacht.
Alternativ guckst du dir das letzte Video an, was ich dazu gemacht habe mit der Bewerbung.
Da erzähle ich es.
Zumindest wie der neue Job heißt.
Alles klar.
Das stimmt übrigens nicht mehr.
Das stimmt nicht mehr.
Neuer Job ist unterschrieben und Kündigung ist eingereicht, kann man da reinschreiben.
Genau so.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Lachs mit Nudeln und China-Chinesen-Sauce.
Wir sehen uns bis dann, machts gut.
See you.